This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For decades, people have been trying to figure out how to create a cigarette without many of the downsides. You know, the things that make smoking the biggest cause of preventable death in America. The tar, the carcinogens, and all that stuff. Cigarette companies tried to create quote-unquote safe combustion-free smoking devices as far back as the 1980s. They were all huge flops. Then in the 2000s, e-cigarettes first hit the market. These early models looked almost like cigarettes, but they gave themselves away in subtle ways.
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For decades, people have been trying to figure out how to create a cigarette without many of the downsides. You know, the things that make smoking the biggest cause of preventable death in America. The tar, the carcinogens, and all that stuff. Cigarette companies tried to create quote-unquote safe combustion-free smoking devices as far back as the 1980s. They were all huge flops. Then in the 2000s, e-cigarettes first hit the market. These early models looked almost like cigarettes, but they gave themselves away in subtle ways.|||这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。几十年来，人们一直在设法创造一种没有那么多负面影响的香烟。你知道的，也就是让吸烟成为美国可预防死亡最大元凶的那些东西——焦油、致癌物以及所有这些成分。早在20世纪80年代，烟草公司就试图创造所谓的安全无燃烧吸烟装置。它们全都以惨败告终。到了20世纪20年代（注：原文2000s，指2000年代），电子烟首次进入市场。这些早期型号看起来几乎和香烟一模一样，但它们在一些微妙的地方露出了马脚。
If you looked really closely, you could see that they were made of plastic or metal, and they had a little glowing light on the tip, meant to resemble the cherry at the end of a lit cigarette. Or you might remember the big clunky vaporizers that resembled walkie-talkies and required users to tinker with battery coils and pour so-called e-liquid into them by hand. None of these ended up breaking into the mainstream. Until, in 2015, a company called Jewel Labs
If you looked really closely, you could see that they were made of plastic or metal, and they had a little glowing light on the tip, meant to resemble the cherry at the end of a lit cigarette. Or you might remember the big clunky vaporizers that resemble walkie-talkies and required users to tinker with battery coils and pour so-called e-liquid into them by hand. None of these ended up breaking into the mainstream. Until, in 2015, a company called Jewel Labs|||如果你仔细观察，就会发现它们是塑料或金属制成的，笔尖还有一个发光的小灯，旨在模仿点燃香烟末端的烟火。或者你可能还记得那些笨重的大型雾化器，它们看起来像对讲机，需要用户自己鼓捣电池线圈，并亲手将所谓的烟油倒进去。这些产品最终都没有进入主流市场。直到2015年，一家名为朱尔实验室（Juul Labs）的公司
rolled out a new nicotine vape that caught fire, both with adult smokers who used them to kick their old-fashioned smoking habit and with young people, children who just thought they were cool. The jewel became a phenomenon, not strictly speaking as a smoking cessation device, but as an entirely new habit, jeweling.
rolled out a new nicotine vape that caught fire, both with adult smokers who used them to kick their old-fashioned smoking habit and with young people, children who just thought they were cool. The jewel became a phenomenon, not strictly speaking as a smoking cessation device, but as an entirely new habit, jeweling.|||推出了一款新型尼古丁电子烟，它迅速火了起来——既受到用来戒除传统吸烟习惯的成年烟民的追捧，也受到那些仅仅觉得它很酷的年轻人和孩子们的喜爱。Juul成了一种社会现象，严格来说不是作为戒烟工具，而是一种全新的习惯——“抽Juul（jueling）”。
In addition to limiting some of the harm of smoking, it seemed to threaten an entire generation with nicotine addiction. The new podcast Backfired, The Vaping Wars dives into the stories behind the jewel's success and its failures. Listening to the show, it's clear that what began as an arguably promising innovation in harm reduction inspired a backlash that in turn opened the door to a veritable Wild West of vaping products. Today we're going to present you with the first episode in which hosts Leon Neffock and
In addition to limiting some of the harm of smoking, it seemed to threaten an entire generation with nicotine addiction. The new podcast Backfired, The Vaping Wars dives into the stories behind the jewel's success and its failures. Listening to the show, it's clear that what began as an arguably promising innovation in harm reduction inspired a backlash that in turn opened the door to a veritable Wild West of vaping products. Today we're going to present you with the first episode in which hosts Leon Neffock and|||除了限制吸烟的部分危害之外，它似乎还用尼古丁成瘾威胁了一整代人。全新播客节目《事与愿违：电子烟之战》（Backfired: The Vaping Wars）深入探讨了Juul成功与失败背后的故事。听了这档节目，我们可以清楚地看到，最初一个可以说是颇具前景的减害创新，却引发了一场强烈反派，进而为电子烟产品真正的“美国西部大荒漠”敞开了大门。今天我们将为您呈上第一期节目，主持人利昂·内夫克（Leon Neyfok）和
Ariel Pardes track how Joule's founders figured out that the right combination of chemistry and design could unlock their product's potential and enhance its addictive qualities. It's really fascinating stuff. Check it out. One afternoon last fall, I sent a Slack message to Ariel Pardes, my co-host on this podcast. I needed to tell her something. I feel nervous. to tell her something. I feel nervous. Because every time a conversation starts with, I need to tell you something. It's not good.
Ariel Pardes track how Joule's founders figured out that the right combination of chemistry and design could unlock their product's potential and enhance its addictive qualities. It's really fascinating stuff. Check it out. One afternoon last fall, I sent a Slack message to Ariel Pardes, my co-host on this podcast. I needed to tell her something. I feel nervous. to tell her something. I feel nervous. Because every time a conversation starts with, I need to tell you something. It's not good.|||阿丽尔·帕德斯（Ariel Pardes）将在节目中追踪Juul的创始人是如何发现化学与设计的完美结合能够释放产品的潜力并增强其成瘾特性的。这真的是非常吸引人的内容。快去听听吧。去年秋天的一个下午，我给这档播客的联合主持人阿丽尔·帕德斯发了一条Slack消息。我得告诉她一件事。我感到很紧张。得告诉她一件事。我感到很紧张。因为每次对话以“我得告诉你件事”开头时。通常都不是什么好事。
Generally not good, but this one could be good. I don't know. I'm gonna remain optimistic. Ariel and I had spent months reporting on vaping, trying to figure out how it had gone from a niche hobby to a billion-dollar industry in the space of just a decade. And the entire time we were doing this, I was also trying to quit vaping myself and telling Ariel about it. Sometimes. Yesterday when we were recording, we can probably play this clip because I'm pretty sure we
Generally not good, but this one could be good. I don't know. I'm gonna remain optimistic. Ariel and I had spent months reporting on vaping, trying to figure out how it had gone from a niche hobby to a billion-dollar industry in the space of just a decade. And the entire time we were doing this, I was also trying to quit vaping myself and telling Ariel about it. Sometimes. Yesterday when we were recording, we can probably play this clip because I'm pretty sure we|||通常不是什么好事，但这件事也可能是件好事。我不知道。我会保持乐观。我和阿丽尔花了好几个月时间报道电子烟，试图弄清楚它如何在短短十年内从一个小众爱好变成了一个价值数十亿美元的产业。在我们做这件事的整个过程中，我自己也一直在试图戒掉电子烟，并把这件事告诉了阿丽尔。有时是这样。昨天我们在录音时，我们大概可以播放这段音频，因为我很确定当时我们
were rowing. Oh, no. At one point, you were like... Leon, was that a vape? No. That did really sound like a vape. I don't vape anymore. What was that sound? I don't know.
were rowing. Oh, no. At one point, you were like... Leon, was that a vape? No. That did really sound like a vape. I don't vape anymore. What was that sound? I don't know.|||在争论。哦，不。有一会儿，你突然说……利昂，那是电子烟的声音吗？没有。那听起来真的很像电子烟。我早就不抽电子烟了。那是什么声音？我不知道。
Yeah, I was on my phone for a second. Don't lie to us, Leon. I'm not lying. I'm not on tape. I'm not lying. The phone makes a weird sound sometimes. I just flatly lied being like, it's not, and we moved on, but it was a vape. Why did you lie? Because I really thought it was going to be my own little secret until I threw it away later in the day. And it was, if literally only I knew, it was gonna be my own little secret until I threw it away later in the day. And if it was, if literally only I knew,
Yeah, I was on my phone for a second. Don't lie to us, Leon. I'm not lying. I'm not on tape. I'm not lying. The phone makes a weird sound sometimes. I just flatly lied being like, it's not, and we moved on, but it was a vape. Why did you lie? Because I really thought it was going to be my own little secret until I threw it away later in the day. And it was, if literally only I knew, it was gonna be my own little secret until I threw it away later in the day. And if it was, if literally only I knew,|||对，我刚才看了一下手机。别对我们撒谎，利昂。我没撒谎。我的录音里没有。我没撒谎。手机有时候会发出奇怪的声音。我当时一口咬定说“不是”，然后我们就继续往下聊了，但那确实是电子烟。你为什么要撒谎？因为我真的以为这会是我自己的一个小秘密，直到我那天晚些时候把它扔掉。而且确实如此，如果真的只有我知道的话，这就会是我自己的一个小秘密，直到我那天晚些时候把它扔掉。如果真是这样，如果真的只有我知道，
it would be like it never happened. That's why I lied. But it's literally on tape. We all knew it happened and now there's concrete proof of it. Damn. Damn. Well, thank you for your delayed honesty and-
it would be like it never happened. That's why I lied. But it's literally on tape. We all knew it happened and now there's concrete proof of it. Damn. Damn. Well, thank you for your delayed honesty and-|||那就好像它从未发生过一样。这就是我撒谎的原因。但录音清清楚楚地记录下来了。我们都知道它发生了，现在还有了确凿的证据。该死。该死。好吧，谢谢你迟来的诚实，以及——
Sorry, I lied to you. I forgive you. A few years ago, there was really only one vaping product that I and everyone else I knew was using. The Juul. In fact, that's what I thought we'd be making this podcast about. Juul. But once we dug into it, we discovered there are now literally thousands of vape brands
Sorry, I lied to you. I forgive you. A few years ago, there was really only one vaping product that I and everyone else I knew was using. The Juul. In fact, that's what I thought we'd be making this podcast about. Juul. But once we dug into it, we discovered there are now literally thousands of vape brands|||对不起，我向你撒了谎。我原谅你。几年前，我和我认识的所有人真正在使用的电子烟产品其实只有一种。那就是Juul。事实上，我原本以为我们这档播客要讲的就是Juul。但一旦我们深入挖掘，我们就会发现现在市场上实际上有数千个电子烟品牌
on the market in flavors like luscious lemon and watermelon ice and cheesecake. You know the Cambrian explosion that's responsible for all the world's biodiversity? That's kind of where we're at with nicotine vapes right now. And I unfortunately have sampled a lot of them. I've tried the Airbar, I've tried Elf bars, I've tried Esco bars, I've tried Miley's, and I like them. I hate how much I like them and I hate how hard it is for me to stop using them. I bought one this morning.
on the market in flavors like luscious lemon and watermelon ice and cheesecake. You know the Cambrian explosion that's responsible for all the world's biodiversity? That's kind of where we're at with nicotine vapes right now. And I unfortunately have sampled a lot of them. I've tried the Airbar, I've tried Elf bars, I've tried Esco bars, I've tried Miley's, and I like them. I hate how much I like them and I hate how hard it is for me to stop using them. I bought one this morning.|||其口味包括甘美柠檬、西瓜冰和芝士蛋糕。你知道那个造就了全世界生物多样性的寒武纪大爆发吗？目前的尼古丁电子烟市场差不多就是那个状态。而不幸的是，我尝试过其中很多种。我试过Airbar，试过Elf bars，试过Esco bars，试过Miley's，而且我都挺喜欢。我讨厌自己这么喜欢它们，我也讨厌要戒掉它们有多么困难。我今天早上刚买了一个。
Why did you buy an air bar this morning? Because my air bar died last night. You know that's not what I meant. Watching Leon grapple with his addiction was pretty eye-opening for me. I didn't grow up around anyone who smoked cigarettes, and as an adult in the Bay Area, I didn't know many people who vaped either.
Why did you buy an air bar this morning? Because my air bar died last night. You know that's not what I meant. Watching Leon grapple with his addiction was pretty eye-opening for me. I didn't grow up around anyone who smoked cigarettes, and as an adult in the Bay Area, I didn't know many people who vaped either.|||你今天早上为什么买air bar？因为我的air bar昨晚没电坏了。你知道我问的不是这个。看着利昂与他的烟瘾做斗争对我来说真是大开眼界。我在成长过程中身边没有人抽烟，作为一个成年人在湾区生活时，我也不认识多少抽电子烟的人。
In fact, in 2019, I voted to ban the sale of nicotine vapes in San Francisco. They just seemed obviously bad. So when we started working on this podcast, I wondered if our reporting would change my mind. My feelings about vaping were complicated. When I was growing up, both of my parents smoked cigarettes and I picked up the habit when I got to college.
In fact, in 2019, I voted to ban the sale of nicotine vapes in San Francisco. They just seemed obviously bad. So when we started working on this podcast, I wondered if our reporting would change my mind. My feelings about vaping were complicated. When I was growing up, both of my parents smoked cigarettes and I picked up the habit when I got to college.|||事实上，在2019年，我还投票支持禁止在旧金山销售尼古丁电子烟。它们当时看起来显然是害处多多的。因此，当我们开始制作这档播客时，我在想我们的报道是否会改变我的想法。我对电子烟的感情很复杂。在我成长过程中，我的父母都抽烟，而我上大学时也染上了这个习惯。
Then during my senior year, my dad died of lung cancer. He was just 47 years old. And yet, even after that, I had a really hard time quitting. I tried nicotine patches and gum and even hypnosis, and nothing ever stuck until I discovered the jewel. And honestly, it was a godsend. If I had a Juul in my pocket, I just didn't smoke cigarettes or even think about them. But at the same time, because I Juuled all day, including inside at my desk, I became
Then during my senior year, my dad died of lung cancer. He was just 47 years old. And yet, even after that, I had a really hard time quitting. I tried nicotine patches and gum and even hypnosis, and nothing ever stuck until I discovered the jewel. And honestly, it was a godsend. If I had a Juul in my pocket, I just didn't smoke cigarettes or even think about them. But at the same time, because I Juuled all day, including inside at my desk, I became|||接着在我大四那年，我父亲死于肺癌。他当时年仅47岁。然而，即使在那之后，我也很难戒掉。我尝试过尼古丁贴剂、口香糖甚至催眠，但没有一样能坚持下来，直到我发现了Juul。老实说，这简直是天赐之物。如果我的口袋里有一支Juul，我就不会抽香烟，甚至连想都不会想。但与此同时，因为我整天都在抽Juul，包括在室内的办公桌旁，我变得
way more addicted to nicotine than I ever was as a smoker. All of this is why, when we first started our reporting, we weren't sure how to feel about Juul and all of the vape companies that have come since. Were they saving people's lives? Or profiting off of their weaknesses? It's safe to say we've both been shocked by what we've learned as we've spent the past year trying to get to the bottom of who is winning and who is losing what we've come to think of as the vaping wars.
way more addicted to nicotine than I ever was as a smoker. All of this is why, when we first started our reporting, we weren't sure how to feel about Juul and all of the vape companies that have come since. Were they saving people's lives? Or profiting off of their weaknesses? It's safe to say we've both been shocked by what we've learned as we've spent the past year trying to get to the bottom of who is winning and who is losing what we've come to think of as the vaping wars.|||对尼古丁的成瘾程度远超我当烟民时的任何时候。所有这些就是为什么当我们刚开始做报道时，我们不确定该如何看待Juul以及此后涌现的所有电子烟公司。它们是在拯救人们的生命吗？还是在利用人们的弱点牟利？可以肯定的是，在过去一年里，当我们试图弄清楚在这场被我们视为“电子烟之战”的博弈中谁赢谁输时，我们都被所了解到的情况震惊了。
Because it's not just one war. There's the war for dominance in the market. Send the logo and the flavor you want and these Chinese manufacturers will send you tens of thousands of them. Jewel is like not cool anymore. It's the puff bar. Elf Bar and Esco Bar have not received FDA authorization. Thousands of unauthorized vapes are pouring into the United States from China.
Because it's not just one war. There's the war for dominance in the market. Send the logo and the flavor you want and these Chinese manufacturers will send you tens of thousands of them. Jewel is like not cool anymore. It's the puff bar. Elf Bar and Esco Bar have not received FDA authorization. Thousands of unauthorized vapes are pouring into the United States from China.|||因为这不只是一场战争。首先是争夺市场主导地位的战争。发去你想要的标志和口味，这些中国制造商就会给你发来数万个。Juul好像不再那么酷了。现在流行的是Puff bar。Elf Bar和Esco Bar并未获得美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的授权。数以千计未经授权的电子烟正从中国涌入美国。
It's almost like we just can't stop this. We are at the cusp of something that could be a catastrophe. And there's also a war between two bitterly opposed camps. One focused on preventing a new generation from getting addicted to nicotine. They came into a kids' school. This is predatory behavior. And the other focused on the potential of vapes to save millions of lives. First puff, I knew that I was going to quit smoking.
It's almost like we just can't stop this. We are at the cusp of something that could be a catastrophe. And there's also a war between two bitterly opposed camps. One focused on preventing a new generation from getting addicted to nicotine. They came into a kids' school. This is predatory behavior. And the other focused on the potential of vapes to save millions of lives. First puff, I knew that I was going to quit smoking.|||这简直就像是我们根本无法阻止这一切。我们正处于一场可能酿成灾难的边缘。此外，还有两个激烈对立的阵营之间的战争。一方致力于阻止新一代人对尼古丁上瘾。他们跑进了孩子们的学校。这是掠夺性的行为。而另一方则专注于电子烟拯救数百万生命的潜力。吸第一口时，我就知道我要戒烟了。
But before all that, there was first Jules War on Big Tobacco, which began at Stanford University before the first vape had even hit the market. That's where we're going to begin our story. Two decades ago, when two graduate students in a design program came up with what seemed like a simple solution to the problem of cigarettes. I remember being like, this is it. This is the dream. I'm Arielle Pardes.
But before all that, there was first Jules War on Big Tobacco, which began at Stanford University before the first vape had even hit the market. That's where we're going to begin our story. Two decades ago, when two graduate students in a design program came what seemed like a simple solution to the problem of cigarettes. I remember being like, this is it. This is the dream. I'm Arielle Pardes.|||但在这一切之前，首先是Juul对大烟草公司的战争，这场战争在第一款电子烟甚至尚未上市之前就始于斯坦福大学。这就是我们要开始讲述的故事。二十年前，设计专业的两名研究生提出了一个看似简单的香烟问题解决方案。我记得当时的感觉是：就是这个。这就是梦想。我是阿丽尔·帕德斯。
I've been a reporter covering Silicon Valley for publications like Wired and The Information for the last eight years. And I'm Leon Neyfok, host of the podcast, Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. From Audible originals and prologue projects, this is Backfired, a podcast about the business of unintended consequences. Episode 1, Smoking Gun. In January of 2015, a 30-something entrepreneur named James Monsies sat down for an interview
I've been a reporter covering Silicon Valley for publications like Wired and The Information for the last eight years. And I'm Leon Neyfok, host of the podcast, Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. From Audible originals and prologue projects, this is Backfired, a podcast about the business of unintended consequences. Episode 1, Smoking Gun. In January of 2015, a 30-something entrepreneur named James Monsies sat down for an interview|||在过去的八年里，我一直担任《连线》（Wired）和《The Information》等刊物的记者，报道硅谷。我是利昂·内夫克，播客节目《Fiasco》的主持人，也是《Slow Burn》的联合创作者。由Audible原创和Prologue项目倾力呈现，这是《事与愿违》（Backfired），一档关于意料之外后果的商业播客。第1集：烟枪实锤（Smoking Gun）。2015年1月，一位30多岁名叫詹姆斯·蒙西斯（James Monsees）的企业家坐下来接受了一次采访
with a journalist. It was just a few months before the jewel would be released. I had only started this in grad school and at Stanford. And we didn't really have, like, a hard-set goal on starting a company out of it. The past decade had been a struggle, but Monsi's felt like the company he had co-founded with his classmate Adam Bowen
with a journalist. It was just a few months before the jewel would be released. I had only started this in grad school and at Stanford. And we didn't really have, like, a hard-set goal on starting a company out of it. The past decade had been a struggle, but Monsi's felt like the company he had co-founded with his classmate Adam Bowen|||与一位记者。当时距离Juul发布仅几个月之遥。我是在读研究生时、在斯坦福开始做这件事的。我们当时其实并没有一个硬性规定要以此创立一家公司。过去的十年是一场斗争，但蒙西斯觉得，他和同班同学亚当·鲍恩（Adam Bowen）共同创立的公司
was finally on the cusp of revolutionizing the world of nicotine. So he was ready to tell their origin story. So you wanted to start at the beginning? I want to start at the beginning. Okay. That's easy. If I can remember it now. It's been so long. I'm just kidding. It's permanently ingrained in my mind.
was finally on the cusp of revolutionizing the world of nicotine. So he was ready to tell their origin story. So you wanted to start at the beginning? I want to start at the beginning. Okay. That's easy. If I can remember it now. It's been so long. I'm just kidding. It's permanently ingrained in my mind.|||终于处于彻底变革尼古丁世界的边缘。因此，他准备讲述他们的起源故事。所以你想从头说起？我想从头说起。好的。那很简单。如果我现在还记得的话。已经过去这么久了。我开玩笑呢。它已经永远铭刻在我的脑海里了。
Bowen and Monsies had met over a decade earlier, in 2003, when they were both enrolled in a master's program at Stanford. The program was a mix of art, mechanical engineering, and industrial design. in 2003 when they were both enrolled in a master's program at Stanford. The program was a mix of art, mechanical engineering, and industrial design. Traditionally, 90% or so of the people that came out of that program would start companies. People who showed up in this program weren't just in grad school to be in grad school. They were on a mission. This is Liz Gerber. She attended the program around the same time as Bowen and Monsey's. People were talking about the power of technology, the potential of connecting people,
Bowen and Monsies had met over a decade earlier, in 2003, when they were both enrolled in a master's program at Stanford. The program was a mix of art, mechanical engineering, and industrial design. in 2003 when they were both enrolled in a master's program at Stanford. The program was a mix of art, mechanical engineering, and industrial design. Traditionally, 90% or so of the people that came out of that program would start companies. People who showed up in this program weren't just in grad school to be in grad school. They were on a mission. This is Liz Gerber. She attended the program around the same time as Bowen and Monsey's. People were talking about the power of technology, the potential of connecting people,|||鲍恩和蒙西斯在十多年前的2003年就认识了，当时他们都在斯坦福大学攻读硕士学位。该项目是艺术、机械工程和工业 design（工业设计）的结合。在2003年，当他们俩都注册了斯坦福大学的硕士项目时。该项目融合了艺术、机械工程和工业设计。按照传统，从那个项目出来的大约90%的人都会创业。出现在这个项目中的人不仅仅是为了读研而读研。他们肩负着使命。这是莉兹·格伯（Liz Gerber）。她和鲍恩、蒙西斯差不多同一时期参加了这个项目。人们在谈论技术的力量、连接人们的潜力，
the discussion about unintended consequences in the product design world was minimal. Just to place you in this moment in time, 2003 was the year MySpace debuted. Apple introduced the iTunes Music Store, and WordPress helped kick off the blogging era. We were doing things in a different way at that time. Anything felt possible, and it wasn't commercially driven. It was really, let's envision the future in which we want to live. As she hung around Stanford's campus, Gerber became friendly with Bowen and Monsey's. She watched as the two started to tinker with various product
the discussion about unintended consequences in the product design world was minimal. Just to place you in this moment in time, 2003 was the year MySpace debuted. Apple introduced the iTunes Music Store, and WordPress helped kick off the blogging era. We were doing things in a different way at that time. Anything felt possible, and it wasn't commercially driven. It was really, let's envision the future in which we want to live. As she hung around Stanford's campus, Gerber became friendly with Bowen and Monsey's. She watched as the two started to tinker with various product|||产品设计界对非预期后果的讨论却少之又少。为了让你回到那个时刻，2003年是MySpace首次亮相的一年。苹果推出了iTunes音乐商店，WordPress则帮助拉开了博客时代的序幕。那时我们以一种不同的方式做事。一切皆有可能，而且它不是由商业驱动的。它真的是，让我们设想我们想要生活的未来。在斯坦福校园里闲逛时，格伯和鲍恩、蒙西斯成了朋友。她看着这两人开始摆弄各种产品
ideas in the school's legendary design lab. Ideas like furniture that could be molded into different shapes, as well as high tech business cards that would transmit your information with a single tap. But Gerber remembers that it wasn't just their work that made Bowen and Monsey's stand out. Everybody knew each other, but the smokers definitely knew each other.
ideas in the school's legendary design lab. Ideas like furniture that could be molded into different shapes, as well as high tech business cards that would transmit your information with a single tap. But Gerber remembers that it wasn't just their work that made Bowen and Monsey's stand out. Everybody knew each other, but the smokers definitely knew each other.|||学校传奇设计实验室里的创意。比如可以塑造成不同形状的家具的创意，以及只需轻轻一按就能传输你信息的顶级科技名片。但格伯记得，让鲍恩和蒙西斯脱颖而出的不仅仅是他们的工作。每个人都互相认识，但吸烟者绝对互相认识。
There were about four students who regularly smoked. By 2003, smoking rates among young people were in freefall. I remember being very much in the minority in college when I would smoke outside of our dorm. Bowen and Monsey's experienced much the same thing. I remember I once took them to task for smoking right outside the door.
There were about four students who regularly smoked. By 2003, smoking rates among young people were in freefall. I remember being like, very much in the minority in college when I would smoke outside of our dorm. Bowen and Monsey's experienced much the same thing. I remember I once took them to task for smoking right outside the door.|||大约有四名学生经常抽烟。到2003年，年轻人的吸烟率正在急剧下降。我记得在大学里，当我站在宿舍外抽烟时，我属于绝对的少数派。鲍恩和蒙西斯也有着差不多的经历。我记得我曾因为他们在大门口抽烟而训斥过他们。
Because I was like, hey guys, like, this is the way I get in. This is the way everybody has to get in. Like, fine smoke, but smoke somewhere away from where everybody has to, you know, come in and out of the door. Monsey's in particular felt shame over his smoking. His grandfather, a smoker, had died from lung cancer. And growing up, Monsey's mom taught him to hate cigarettes.
Because I was like, hey guys, like, this is the way I get in. This is the way everybody has to get in. Like, fine smoke, but smoke somewhere away from where everybody has to, you know, come in and out of the door. Monsey's in particular felt shame over his smoking. His grandfather, a smoker, had died from lung cancer. And growing up, Monsey's mom taught him to hate cigarettes.|||因为我说，嘿，伙计们，这是我进出的通道。这也是所有人必须进出的通道。比如，你想抽烟可以，但请去离每个人都必须进出大门的远一点的地方抽。蒙西斯对自己的吸烟行为感到格外羞耻。他的祖父是个烟民，死于肺癌。在蒙西斯成长过程中，他的母亲教导他要痛恨香烟。
And yet, he picked up the habit anyway. Then, one day, he was having a cigarette with Bowen outside the design lab, and a light bulb went off. We just kind of looked at each other and thought, you know, this would be a really interesting space to look at. And then the safety and shelter of academia, right, why not look at something that's a huge opportunity and a huge sort of social problem.
And yet, he picked up the habit anyway. Then, one day, he was having a cigarette with Bowen outside the design lab, and a light bulb went off. We just kind of looked at each other and thought, you know, this would be a really interesting space to look at. And then the safety and shelter of academia, right, why not look at something that's a huge opportunity and a huge sort of social problem.|||然而，他最后还是染上了这个习惯。然后有一天，他和鲍恩在设计实验室外面抽烟时，脑子里突然灵光一现。我们俩互相对视了一眼，心想，你知道吗，这会是一个非常有趣的领域去探索。在学术界的庇护所和安全感之下，对吧，为什么不着眼于一个巨大的机遇和一个巨大的某种社会问题呢。
What they realized was that there were a lot of smokers who wanted to quit, and no one had come up with a truly effective way to help them do it. Bowen and Monsey's decided this was the problem they wanted to focus on in their master's thesis. So they got to work researching their idea. That was when they discovered a number of earlier attempts by big tobacco companies to create a safer cigarette. Among them was the Premier, which R.J. Reynolds released in 1988. Premier is the premier of a cigarette
What they realized was that there were a lot of smokers who wanted to quit, and no one had come up with a truly effective way to help them do it. Bowen and Monsey's decided this was the problem they wanted to focus on in their master's thesis. So they got to work researching their idea. That was when they discovered a number of earlier attempts by big tobacco companies to create a safer cigarette. Among them was the Premier, which R.J. Reynolds released in 1988. Premier is the premier of a cigarette|||他们意识到，有很多烟民想要戒烟，但没有人提出真正有效的方法来帮助他们做到这一点。鲍恩和蒙西斯决定，这就是他们要在硕士论文中重点研究的问题。于是他们开始着手研究他们的想法。正是在那时，他们发现了大型烟草公司此前为制造更安全香烟而进行的多次尝试。其中包括雷诺公司（R.J. Reynolds）于1988年发布的Premier。Premier是香烟中的首款产品
which heats tobacco rather than burns it, thus eliminating most of the smoke, much of the odor, and all of the ash. Under the code name Project Spa, R.J. Reynolds spent years and hundreds of millions of dollars developing the device. The big innovation behind it was that it heated tobacco instead of burning it, thereby removing the most dangerous part of smoking, the combustion that creates tar.
which heats tobacco rather than burns it, thus eliminating most of the smoke, much of the odor, and all of the ash. Under the code name Project Spa, R.J. Reynolds spent years and hundreds of millions of dollars developing the device. The big innovation behind it was that it heated tobacco instead of burning it, thereby removing the most dangerous part of smoking, the combustion that creates tar.|||它通过加热而不是燃烧烟草，从而消除了大部分烟雾、大部分气味以及所有的烟灰。在代号为“Spa计划”的项目下，R.J.雷诺公司花费了数年时间和数亿美元开发该设备。其背后的重大创新在于它加热烟草而不是燃烧烟草，从而去除了吸烟中最危险的部分——产生焦油的燃烧过程。
Still, Reynolds was careful not to say that the Premier was safer, just that it was cleaner. We substantially reduced many of the controversial compounds found in the smoke of tobacco burning cigarettes, virtually eliminate side stream smoke, no ash. There is a cleaner taste. It is a different taste. But that different taste wasn't a hit with early users. It doesn't taste like you're smoking tobacco. What does it taste like?
Still, Reynolds was careful not to say that the Premier was safer, just that it was cleaner. We substantially reduced many of the controversial compounds found in the smoke of tobacco burning cigarettes, virtually eliminate side stream smoke, no ash. There is a cleaner taste. It is a different taste. But that different taste wasn't a hit with early users. It doesn't taste like you're smoking tobacco. What does it taste like?|||尽管如此，雷诺公司还是小心翼翼地没有说Premier更安全，只是说它更干净。我们大幅减少了燃烧烟草香烟的烟雾中发现的许多有争议的化合物，几乎消除了侧支烟雾，没有烟灰。口感更干净。这是一种不同的口感。但这种不同的口感并没有受到早期用户的欢迎。它抽起来不像在抽烟草。那它尝起来像什么？
Like you're smoking plastic. Reynolds gave up on the premiere after a short test period. But as Bowen and Monsi's found out, that was not the end of Big Tobacco's efforts to create a safer cigarette. In 1998, Philip Morris released the Accord. Accord is really a smoking system. It includes what would appear to be a traditional cigarette that
Like you're smoking plastic. Reynolds gave up on the premiere after a short test period. But as Bowen and Monsi's found out, that was not the end of Big Tobacco's efforts to create a safer cigarette. In 1998, Philip Morris released the Accord. Accord is really a smoking system. It includes what would appear to be a traditional cigarette that|||就像你在抽塑料。在经历了短暂的测试期后，雷诺公司放弃了Premier。但正如鲍恩和蒙西斯所发现的那样，这并不是大烟草公司制造更安全香烟努力的终点。1998年，菲利普·莫里斯（Philip Morris）推出了Accord。Accord实际上是一个吸烟系统。它包括看起来像传统香烟的东西
is inserted into a special lighter. The lighter has sensors in it and when you take a puff it burns the tobacco in the cigarette. Like the Premier, the Accord was designed to vaporize tobacco leaves by gently heating them, which was supposed to prevent users from inhaling deadly chemicals. But also like the Premier, the Accord tasted bad and failed to take off with customers. The timing was also not great. As it happened, the accord was released just as Philip Morris, along with several other
is inserted into a special lighter. The lighter has sensors in it and when you take a puff it burns the tobacco in the cigarette. Like the Premier, the Accord was designed to vaporize tobacco leaves by gently heating them, which was supposed to prevent users from inhaling deadly chemicals. But also like the Premier, the Accord tasted bad and failed to take off with customers. The timing was also not great. As it happened, the accord was released just as Philip Morris, along with several other|||将其插入特殊的打火机中。打火机内设有传感器，当你抽一口时，它会燃烧香烟中的烟草。与Premier一样，Accord旨在通过温和加热烟叶将其气化，这本应防止用户吸入致命的化学物质。但同样与Premier类似，Accord味道很糟糕，也没有在客户中流行开来。推出的时机也不是很好。巧合的是，accord发布时，菲利普·莫里斯以及其他几家
big tobacco companies, agreed to pay billions of dollars in a court ordered settlement. This settlement is clearly an important step in the right direction for our country. It reflects the first time tobacco companies will be held financially accountable for the damage their product does to our nation's health, and the long struggle to protect our children from tobacco. As part of the settlement, tobacco companies were forced to make millions of internal documents public, including some that showed they had lied about the health risks of smoking. This database was released just two years before Bowen and Monsey's had their revelation
big tobacco companies, agreed to pay billions of dollars in a court ordered settlement. This settlement is clearly an important step in the right direction for our country. It reflects the first time tobacco companies will be held financially accountable for the damage their product does to our nation's health, and the long struggle to protect our children from tobacco. As part of the settlement, tobacco companies were forced to make millions of internal documents public, including some that showed they had lied about the health risks of smoking. This database was released just two years before Bowen and Monsey's had their revelation|||大型烟草公司同意支付数十亿美元的法院命令和解金。这项协议显然是我们国家朝着正确方向迈出的重要一步。它反映了烟草公司历史上第一次对其产品对我国健康造成的损害承担财务责任，以及为保护我们的孩子免受烟草侵害而进行的长期斗争。作为和解协议的一部分，烟草公司被迫公开数百万份内部文件，其中一些文件显示他们曾对吸烟的健康风险撒谎。这个数据库的发布距离鲍恩和蒙西斯顿悟仅两年时间
outside the Stanford Design Lab. In fact, it's where they found out about all the early failed attempts at safer cigarettes. Now, they could use Big Tobacco's research to beat them at their own game. We got so much information that you wouldn't be able to get in most industries. Yeah. And we were able to catch up to a huge, huge industry in no time. Soon, Bowen and Monsey's started working on a prototype. The key innovation they were keen to tinker with was this idea that if
outside the Stanford Design Lab. In fact, it's where they found out about all the early failed attempts at safer cigarettes. Now, they could use Big Tobacco's research to beat them at their own game. We got so much information that you wouldn't be able to get in most industries. Yeah. And we were able to catch up to a huge, huge industry in no time. Soon, Bowen and Monsey's started working on a prototype. The key innovation they were keen to tinker with was this idea that if|||在斯坦福设计实验室外。事实上，正是在那里，他们了解了早期所有关于制造更安全香烟的失败尝试。现在，他们可以利用大烟草公司的研究成果，在他们自己的地盘上击败他们。我们获得了在大多数行业都无法获得的大量信息。是的。而且我们能够在短时间内赶上一个庞大无比的行业。不久之后，鲍恩和蒙西斯开始着手制作原型机。他们热衷于鼓捣的核心创新是这样一个想法：如果
you heat tobacco leaves at a lower temperature instead of burning them, you can still get nicotine but without the deadly tar that leads to lung cancer. The question was how to design a device that could do that in a way that was portable, satisfying for smokers, and, hopefully, cool to look at. It turned out to be a much bigger challenge than Bowen and Monsey's had anticipated. By June of 2005, Bowen and Monsey's were ready to present their thesis idea to their classmates. It would, hopefully, be the first step toward securing potential funding and turning their product into something more than just a good idea.
you heat tobacco leaves at a lower temperature instead of burning them, you can still get nicotine but without the deadly tar that leads to lung cancer. The question was how to design a device that could do that in a way that was portable, satisfying for smokers, and, hopefully, cool to look at. It turned out to be a much bigger challenge than Bowen and Monsey's had anticipated. By June of 2005, Bowen and Monsey's were ready to present their thesis idea to their classmates. It would, hopefully, be the first step toward securing potential funding and turning their product into something more than just a good idea.|||以较低的温度加热烟叶而不是燃烧它们，你仍然可以获得尼古丁，但不会产生导致肺癌的致命焦油。问题在于如何设计出这样一种设备，使其既便携、让烟民感到满足，又最好看起来很酷。事实证明，这比鲍恩和蒙西斯预期的要挑战得多。到2005年6月，鲍恩和蒙西斯准备向同学们展示他们的论文构想。这有望成为获得潜在资金并将他们的产品变成不仅仅是一个好主意的第一步。
Monsey's introduced the device, which they were now calling Plume, the rational future of smoking. So the name was Salus, and it's now Plume, at least temporarily. Monsey's quickly ran through what he and Bowen had discovered about Big Tobacco's attempts to make a less deadly cigarette and explained why he thought all of them were pretty lame. Really, there's no design innovation going on
Monsey's introduced the device, which they were now calling Plume, the rational future of smoking. So the name was Salus, and it's now Plume, at least temporarily. Monsey's quickly ran through what he and Bowen had discovered about Big Tobacco's attempts to make a less deadly cigarette and explained why he thought all of them were pretty lame. Really, there's no design innovation going on|||蒙西斯介绍了这款设备，他们现在称之为Plume，即理性的吸烟未来。所以名字叫Salus，现在叫Plume，至少是暂时这么叫。蒙西斯迅速浏览了他和鲍恩关于大烟草公司制造危害较小香烟的尝试的发现，并解释了为什么他认为所有这些尝试都很烂。真的，没有任何设计创新在发生
in smoking whatsoever, because Big Tobacco's really interested in not shooting themselves in their own foot. They sell cigarettes, and that's very much what they do. Then it was Bowen's turn to speak. He made the case for why the plume would be different. So our goal was to basically create a whole new experience for people that retains the positive aspects of smoking, like the ritual and everything, but makes it as healthy
in smoking whatsoever, because Big Tobacco's really interested in not shooting themselves in their own foot. They sell cigarettes, and that's very much what they do. Then it was Bowen's turn to speak. He made the case for why the plume would be different. So our goal was to basically create a whole new experience for people that retains the positive aspects of smoking, like the ritual and everything, but makes it as healthy|||在吸烟这件事情上，因为大烟草公司真正感兴趣的是不搬起石头砸自己的脚。他们出售香烟，这就是他们的主要业务。接下来轮到鲍恩发言了。他陈述了Plume为什么会与众不同的理由。所以我们的目标基本上是为人们创造一种全新体验，它保留了吸烟的积极方面，比如仪式感等等，但使其尽可能健康
and socially acceptable as possible. Healthy and socially acceptable as possible. Healthy and socially acceptable. The plume wouldn't be smelly like a cigarette, nor would it raise the ire of classmates like Liz Gerber. Instead, it would be safe, and maybe even cool. We feel that we could take tobacco back to being a laundry good and not so much a sort of drug delivery device that the cigarettes have become.
and socially acceptable as possible. Healthy and socially acceptable as possible. Healthy and socially acceptable. The plume wouldn't be smelly like a cigarette, nor would it raise the ire of classmates like Liz Gerber. Instead, it would be safe, and maybe even cool. We feel that we could take tobacco back to being a laundry good and not so much a sort of drug delivery device that the cigarettes have become.|||并且尽可能被社会所接受。尽可能健康且社会可接受。健康且社会可接受。Plume不会像香烟那样难闻，也不会激起像莉兹·格伯这样的同学的愤怒。相反，它是安全的，甚至可能很酷。我们觉得我们可以让烟草回归为一种生活日用品（注：原文a laundry good疑为lifestyle good或类似词汇的误读），而不是像香烟那样变成某种毒品输送装置。
The plume looked nothing like existing tobacco products. It was sleek. It had a cartridge system that Bowen compared to the Nespresso. And it came in a variety of flavors. When the presentation was over, the room lit up with applause. They had some beautiful drawings. I remember the look of it being very attractive. To Liz Gerber, the plume didn't just look good. There was almost something romantic about it. I also thought the name plume sounded really beautiful. It made me think of like the 1920s flappers with the long cigarettes and like the wavy smoke coming out and it kind of had this elegant association.
The plume looked nothing like existing tobacco products. It was sleek. It had a cartridge system that Bowen compared to the Nespresso. And it came in a variety of flavors. When the presentation was over, the room lit up with applause. They had some beautiful drawings. I remember the look of it being very attractive. To Liz Gerber, the plume didn't just look good. There was almost something romantic about it. I also thought the name plume sounded really beautiful. It made me think of like the 1920s flappers with the long cigarettes and like the wavy smoke coming out and it kind of had this elegant association.|||Plume的外观与现有的烟草产品毫无相似之处。它线条流畅。它拥有一个弹匣系统，鲍恩将其比作奈斯派索（Nespresso）咖啡机。而且它有多种口味可供选择。演示结束后，全场响起雷鸣般的掌声。他们有一些漂亮的图纸。我记得它的外观非常吸引人。在莉兹·格伯看来，Plume不仅外观好看。它甚至带有一种浪漫的色彩。我也觉得plume这个名字听起来非常优美。这让我想起了20世纪20年代那些拿着长烟嘴、吐着袅袅烟圈的时髦女郎，它带有一种优雅的联想。
I remember also thinking about unintended consequences, what if in addition to helping people quit and reducing secondhand smoke, it also makes smoking sexier? After graduating, Bowen and Monsies worked on the plume from a small room in Bowen's house. Their first challenge was to build the device, but in order to do that, they needed money. The problem was, a lot of big venture capital funds were prohibited from investing in the
I remember also thinking about unintended consequences, what if in addition to helping people quit and reducing secondhand smoke, it also makes smoking sexier? After graduating, Bowen and Monsies worked on the plume from a small room in Bowen's house. Their first challenge was to build the device, but in order to do that, they needed money. The problem was, a lot of big venture capital funds were prohibited from investing in the|||我还记得当时想到了非预期后果：如果除了帮助人们戒烟和减少二手烟之外，它还让吸烟变得更性感了呢？毕业后，鲍恩和蒙西斯在鲍恩家的一间小房间里继续研发Plume。他们面临的第一个挑战是制造出这款设备，但为此他们需要资金。问题在于，许多大型风险投资基金被禁止投资于
vice space, which included drugs, alcohol, and even supposedly safe cigarettes. So after getting a few rejections, Bowen and Monsey sent a plea to a Stanford email list. Eventually, a few angel investors agreed to take a chance on the company. By the spring of 2007, Plume raised nearly half a million dollars. And finally, the company was ready to make its first hire. My name is Kurt Sonderager, and I was the first employee at Plume, which went on to become Jewel. In 2007, Kurt Sonderager was a 41-year-old marketing director at Red Bull. He was the kind of person who religiously attended Burning Man and spent his vacations surfing in Bali.
vice space, which included drugs, alcohol, and even supposedly safe cigarettes. So after getting a few rejections, Bowen and Monsey sent a plea to a Stanford email list. Eventually, a few angel investors agreed to take a chance on the company. By the spring of 2007, Plume raised nearly half a million dollars. And finally, the company was ready to make its first hire. My name is Kurt Sonderager, and I was the first employee at Plume, which went on to become Jewel. In 2007, Kurt Sonderager was a 41-year-old marketing director at Red Bull. He was the kind of person who religiously attended Burning Man and spent his vacations surfing in Bali.|||罪恶产业领域，其中包括毒品、酒精，甚至所谓的安全香烟。所以在遭到几次拒绝后，鲍恩和蒙西斯向斯坦福的一个邮件列表发送了求助信。最终，几位天使投资者同意在这家公司上碰碰运气。到2007年春天，Plume筹集了近50万美元。最后，公司准备进行第一次招聘。我叫库尔特·桑德拉格（Kurt Sonderager），我是Plume的第一名员工，后来Plume演变成了Juul。2007年，库尔特·桑德拉格是红牛（Red Bull）公司41岁的市场总监。他是个那种狂热参加“火人节”（Burning Man）、假期都在巴厘岛冲浪的人。
He was also a smoker. I was a long-time smoker, heavily conflicted. I was eating well, exercising a lot, but it was the monkey I couldn't get off my back. One day, Sonderrager received a cryptic LinkedIn message about a new company in need of a marketing director. Bowen and Monsies invited Sonderrager to meet them at a posh hotel in San Francisco.
He was also a smoker. I was a long-time smoker, heavily conflicted. I was eating well, exercising a lot, but it was the monkey I couldn't get off my back. One day, Sonderrager received a cryptic LinkedIn message about a new company in need of a marketing director. Bowen and Monsies invited Sonderrager to meet them at a posh hotel in San Francisco.|||他也是个烟民。我是一个老烟民，内心充满纠结。我饮食健康，经常锻炼，但这个恶习就是怎么也甩不掉。一天，桑德拉格收到了一条语焉不详的领英（LinkedIn）消息，说有一家新公司需要一名市场总监。鲍恩和蒙西斯邀请桑德拉格在旧金山一家豪华酒店与他们会面。
I went to sit down, and there are these two kind of slightly disheveled, you know, graduate student looking guys. And you know, we shook hands, and I want to take things out of my pocket as we do. You know, one of the things when I put it on the table, kind of shockingly, I noticed it was a pack of cigarettes. I was very ashamed of smoking, and it's not something I was proud of. It's certainly not in our first interview with a company I knew nothing about.
I went to sit down, and there are these two kind of slightly disheveled, you know, graduate student looking guys. And you know, we shook hands, and I want to take things out of my pocket as we do. You know, one of the things when I put it on the table, kind of shockingly, I noticed it was a pack of cigarettes. I was very ashamed of smoking, and it's not something I was proud of. It's certainly not in our first interview with a company I knew nothing about.|||我走过去坐下，那里坐着两个看起来有点衣衫不整的、你知道的、像研究生模样的小伙子。你知道的，我们握了手，然后像往常一样我想从口袋里掏点东西出来。你知道的，当我把其中一样东西放在桌上时，令人震惊的是，我发现那是一包香烟。我对吸烟感到非常羞耻，这不是一件让我引以为傲的事。尤其是在面对一家我一无所知的公司的初次面试时，这绝对不应该发生。
And Adam and James kind of looked at each other and smiled slightly. As the meeting went on, Sonderager realized why Bowen and Monsey's were pleased to find out he was a smoker. They told him about plume and described how vaporization worked. One of the things they made very clear was they didn't want it to look like a cigarette. They wanted it to be its own thing that they weren't trying to replicate
And Adam and James kind of looked at each other and smiled slightly. As the meeting went on, Sonderager realized why Bowen and Monsey's were pleased to find out he was a smoker. They told him about plume and described how vaporization worked. One of the things they made very clear was they didn't want it to look like a cigarette. They wanted it to be its own thing that they weren't trying to replicate|||亚当和詹姆斯互相对视了一眼，微微笑了笑。随着会面的进行，桑德拉格意识到为什么鲍恩和蒙西斯发现他是个烟民会感到高兴了。他们向他讲述了Plume，并描述了雾化原理是如何运作的。他们明确指出的一点是，他们不希望它看起来像香烟。他们希望它是独一无二的东西，他们并不是在试图复制
the cigarette paradigm. They were gonna change that paradigm. The plume was still just a prototype, but Sonderager totally bought into the vision. We had nicorette gum, we have patches, we have all kinds of tools that people could use to stop smoking, but it wasn't working. So clearly there's something to the ritual of smoking
the cigarette paradigm. They were gonna change that paradigm. The plume was still just a prototype, but Sonderager totally bought into the vision. We had nicorette gum, we have patches, we have all kinds of tools that people could use to stop smoking, but it wasn't working. So clearly there's something to the ritual of smoking|||香烟的范式。他们要改变那种范式。Plume当时还只是一个原型，但桑德拉格完全被这个愿景吸引了。我们有尼古丁口香糖，我们有贴剂，我们有各种各样的工具供人们戒烟，但就是不管用。所以很明显，吸烟的仪式感中
that smokers really can't let go of, and I bought into that 100%, I'm one of them. Sonderager started at Plume in September of 2007. He likes to tell a story about his first day, when he showed up to find the office had no desks, so he ran out to Home Depot to buy some supplies to make some. And yet, Bowen and Monsies told Sonderager they were planning to launch Plume in just a few months. That was not easy.
that smokers really can't let go of, and I bought into that 100%, I'm one of them. Sonderager started at Plume in September of 2007. He likes to tell a story about his first day, when he showed up to find the office had no desks, so he ran out to Home Depot to buy some supplies to make some. And yet, Bowen and Monsies told Sonderager they were planning to launch Plume in just a few months. That was not easy.|||是烟民们真的无法割舍的，我百分之百赞同这一点，因为我就是其中之一。桑德拉格于2007年9月加入Plume。他喜欢讲一个关于他第一天上班的故事：当时他来到办公室，发现里面连办公桌都没有，于是他跑到家得宝（Home Depot）买了一些材料自己做了一些。然而，鲍恩和蒙西斯却告诉桑德拉格，他们计划在短短几个月内推出Plume。这可不容易。
There was certainly a lot to do, but as a marketing person and not as an engineer, I couldn't really jump in with them on a lot of the things. The only thing I could kind of help out with, other than branding and website and social media and all that stuff, was the flavor development. The plume used a butane flame to heat a tiny metal cup, kind of like an espresso pod, filled with tobacco leaves and mixed with commercial food flavoring. The heat produced a vapor, which would then be inhaled through a mouthpiece.
There was certainly a lot to do, but as a marketing person and not as an engineer, I couldn't really jump in with them on a lot of the things. The only thing I could kind of help out with, other than branding and website and social media and all that stuff, was the flavor development. The plume used a butane flame to heat a tiny metal cup, kind of like an espresso pod, filled with tobacco leaves and mixed with commercial food flavoring. The heat produced a vapor, which would then be inhaled through a mouthpiece.|||确实有很多事情要做，但作为一名市场营销人员而不是工程师，我无法真正深入参与他们的很多工作。除了品牌塑造、网站建设、社交媒体以及所有这些事情之外，我唯一能帮上忙的就是口味研发。Plume使用丁烷火焰加热一个小金属杯（有点像浓缩咖啡胶囊），里面装满了烟叶并混合了商业食用香料。热量产生蒸气，然后通过咬嘴吸入。
Overall, it resembled a large chunky pen. Sonder Eger said he always thought about it as a portable hookah. Kind of a hookah in your pocket. So there were these little pods that had tobacco in them and we didn't wanna just vape the straight tobacco. It's a little bit boring. It doesn't have that much flavor. So following the hookah model, we started with adding different flavors
Overall, it resembled a large chunky pen. Sonder Eger said he always thought about it as a portable hookah. Kind of a hookah in your pocket. So there were these little pods that had tobacco in them and we didn't wanna just vape the straight tobacco. It's a little bit boring. It doesn't have that much flavor. So following the hookah model, we started with adding different flavors|||总体而言，它看起来像一支又大又粗的笔。桑德拉格说，他一直认为它是一个便携式水烟筒。有点像装在你口袋里的水烟筒。所以这些小胶囊里装着烟草，而我们不想只抽纯烟草。那有点无趣。没有那么多味道。因此，仿照水烟的模式，我们开始添加不同的口味
and mixing it with the tobacco before filling these little pods. Bowen and Monsey's had always imagined the plume as a flavored product. Bowen in, was often experimenting by combining tobacco leaves with various flavors in big mixing bowls. Some early flavors included cinnamon and butter.
and mixing it with the tobacco before filling these little pods. Bowen and Monsey's had always imagined the plume as a flavored product. Bowen in, was often experimenting by combining tobacco leaves with various flavors in big mixing bowls. Some early flavors included cinnamon and butter.|||并在填充这些小胶囊之前将其与烟草混合。鲍恩和蒙西斯一直将Plume设想为一个有风味的产品。鲍恩经常在大调酒碗里将烟叶与各种口味混合进行实验。早期的一些口味包括肉桂和黄油。
Bowen would leave pods on Sonderager's desk for him to sample, and eventually they settled on six flavors. Peach. The peach was called orchard. Cafe noir. Gold, which is like a more traditional tobacco flavor. Rocket, which was like a pretty strong flavor.
Bowen would leave pods on Sonderager's desk for him to sample, and eventually they settled on six flavors. Peach. The peach was called orchard. Cafe noir. Gold, which is like a more traditional tobacco flavor. Rocket, which was like a pretty strong flavor.|||鲍恩会把胶囊留在桑德拉格的桌上让他品尝，最终他们确定了六种口味。桃子味。桃子味被称为果园。黑咖啡味。金色，这是一种更传统的烟草口味。火箭味，这是一种相当浓烈的口味。
And the two herbal flavors were blue tea and kick-ass mint. As fun as it was to try out flavors, getting the plume ready for market was taking way longer than the founders and Sonderager had hoped. All of a sudden, it was 2009. The original launch date had come and gone, and they were still testing the plume to mixed reviews. At one point, Sonderager lent a plume to a friend to take to Burning Man. Afterwards, the friend reported that, quote, the harsh Playa conditions did not mix well with plumbing.
And the two herbal flavors were blue tea and kick-ass mint. As fun as it was to try out flavors, getting the plume ready for market was taking way longer than the founders and Sonderager had hoped. All of a sudden, it was 2009. The original launch date had come and gone, and they were still testing the plume to mixed reviews. At one point, Sonderager lent a plume to a friend to take to Burning Man. Afterwards, the friend reported that, quote, the harsh Playa conditions did not mix well with plumbing.|||而两种草本口味则是蓝茶味和劲爽薄荷味。尽管尝试各种口味很有趣，但让Plume做好上市准备所花费的时间远比创始人和桑德拉格所希望的要长。转眼间，时间来到了2009年。最初的发布日期早已过去，他们仍在测试Plume，但评价毁誉参半。有一次，桑德拉格把一支Plume借给一位朋友带去火人节。事后，这位朋友报告说，引述：“海滩（Playa）恶劣的环境与plumbing（此处指pluming，吸Plume）格格不入。”
There are too many working pieces and too many steps in the plumbing process. Sonderger's friend said that by comparison, Siggy's are simple. We pushed ahead anyway because we needed to get something to market. Investors were getting a little bit antsy and we needed to show some results. And at the same time, they knew that they would fail small, fail early, and keep iterating on the design. Finally, in late 2009, so five years after Bowen and Monsi's came up with the idea, they soft launched the plume.
There are too many working pieces and too many steps in the plumbing process. Sonderger's friend said that by comparison, Siggy's are simple. We pushed ahead anyway because we needed to get something to market. Investors were getting a little bit antsy and we needed to show some results. And at the same time, they knew that they would fail small, fail early, and keep iterating on the design. Finally, in late 2009, so five years after Bowen and Monsi's came up with the idea, they soft launched the plume.|||吸Plume的过程中有太多的活动部件和太多的步骤。桑德拉格的朋友说，相比之下，香烟（Siggy's）就简单多了。无论如何，我们还是推进下去了，因为我们需要把产品推向市场。投资者开始有点坐立不安了，我们需要展示一些成果。与此同时，他们深知自己会小失败、早失败，并继续对设计进行迭代。最终，在2009年底，也就是鲍恩和蒙西斯萌生这个想法五年后，他们低调推出了Plume。
Sonder Eger put an image on their website of the black Model 1 with the words, small, dark, and handsome. He also posted on a few message boards that the plume was hitting the market soon. Hundreds of pre-orders came rolling in. A camera crew from a news website paid a visit to their office, and Monsey's demonstrated the model one for the reporter. So I'm pluming this device because I'm not smoking. So then when you inhale you get this vapor. But it's not smoke, it's just vapor. Monsey's went on to compare the process to steeping tea.
Sonder Eger put an image on their website of the black Model 1 with the words, small, dark, and handsome. He also posted on a few message boards that the plume was hitting the market soon. Hundreds of pre-orders came rolling in. A camera crew from a news website paid a visit to their office, and Monsey's demonstrated the model one for the reporter. So I'm pluming this device because I'm not smoking. So then when you inhale you get this vapor. But it's not smoke, it's just vapor. Monsey's went on to compare the process to steeping tea.|||桑德拉格在他们的网站上放了一张黑色1型手机（注：指Model 1型号）的图片，配文是：“小巧、黑暗而帅气（small, dark, and handsome）”。他还在一些留言板上发帖称，Plume即将上市。数百份预订单纷至沓来。一家新闻网站的摄制组造访了他们的办公室，蒙西斯向记者演示了1型设备。所以我正在使用这个设备抽Plume，因为我没有抽烟。所以当你吸气时，你会得到这种蒸气。但这不是烟雾，它只是蒸气。蒙西斯接着将这个过程比作泡茶。
When you put a tea bag into hot water, you're extracting the aroma, you're extracting the caffeine. So we've found a new way to make tea and have a very different experience that's more suited to people who are smokers. So you get the nicotine, you get the flavor, but you don't actually burn the tobacco. The reporter points out that Bowen and Monsey's are steering clear of claiming that the plume is safer than a regular cigarette. Instead, Bowen used a familiar word. Cleaner. We believe that it is a cleaner ritual and
When you put a tea bag into hot water, you're extracting the aroma, you're extracting the caffeine. So we've found a new way to make tea and have a very different experience that's more suited to people who are smokers. So you get the nicotine, you get the flavor, but you don't actually burn the tobacco. The reporter points out that Bowen and Monsey's are steering clear of claiming that the plume is safer than a regular cigarette. Instead, Bowen used a familiar word. Cleaner. We believe that it is a cleaner ritual and|||当你把茶包放进热水里时，你是在提取香气，你是在提取咖啡因。所以我们找到了一种泡茶的新方法，并拥有了更适合烟民的完全不同的体验。因此，你获得了尼古丁，你获得了风味，但你实际上并没有燃烧烟草。记者指出，鲍恩和蒙西斯刻意避开宣称Plume比普通香烟更安全。相反，鲍恩使用了一个熟悉的词：更干净。我们相信这是一种更干净的仪式，并且
alleviates a lot of the social and environmental concerns otherwise ascribed to smoking. And Monsey's finished by further distancing the product from cigarettes. What we've tried to do is create a new paradigm, something that doesn't look like a cigarette, doesn't feel or taste like a cigarette. It's different. The media interest suggested there was some momentum,
alleviates a lot of the social and environmental concerns otherwise ascribed to smoking. And Monsey's finished by further distancing the product from cigarettes. What we've tried to do is create a new paradigm, something that doesn't look like a cigarette, doesn't feel or taste like a cigarette. It's different. The media interest suggested there was some momentum,|||减轻了原本归咎于吸烟的许多社会和环境关切。蒙西斯最后进一步将该产品与香烟划清界限。我们试图做的是创造一种新的范式，一种看起来不像香烟、感觉或味道都不像香烟的东西。它是不同的。媒体的兴趣表明存在一些势头，
but not enough. Like its big tobacco predecessors, the Plume Model 1 was a flop. For one thing, it wasn't satisfying as a nicotine delivery system. Sonderager would often plume all morning and then go downstairs and have a cigarette. But also, often the device just didn't work. Sonderager had a hard time communicating that to the founders. He remembered one instance in particular when Bowen just wasn't accepting the flaws he
but not enough. Like its big tobacco predecessors, the Plume Model 1 was a flop. For one thing, it wasn't satisfying as a nicotine delivery system. Sonderager would often plume all morning and then go downstairs and have a cigarette. But also, often the device just didn't work. Sonderager had a hard time communicating that to the founders. He remembered one instance in particular when Bowen just wasn't accepting the flaws he|||但还远远不够。就像它的大烟草前辈一样，Plume 1型是一个失败的产品。首先，作为尼古丁输送系统，它并不能令人满意。桑德拉格经常整个上午都在用Plume，然后下楼去抽根烟。而且，设备也经常出故障。桑德拉格很难向创始人传达这一点。他特别记得有一次，鲍恩根本不接受他所指出的瑕疵。
was telling him about. I said, look, Adam, just come with me. Let's make the rounds and let's see how this goes. And we went to like five head shops that day. And I remember one of the shops in particular, we went in there cold and presented the device to the guy. I just put it down on the table, I explained how it worked and the guy, everything that could have gone wrong did wrong.
was telling him about. I said, look, Adam, just come with me. Let's make the rounds and let's see how this goes. And we went to like five head shops that day. And I remember one of the shops in particular, we went in there cold and presented the device to the guy. I just put it down on the table, I explained how it worked and the guy, everything that could have gone wrong did wrong.|||我当时说，听着，亚当，跟我来。我们去转转，看看情况如何。那天我们去了大约五家烟具店。我记得其中一家店特别典型，我们毫无预兆地走进去，把设备展示给店员看。我把它放在桌上，解释了它是如何运作的，结果呢，所有可能出错的地方全出错了。
He couldn't get the butane in it. When he went to start it, he shocked his finger. He used it for a little bit, the mouthpiece fell off and he broke his lip. And I remember seeing Adam's face just like he knew that these were problems, but when he saw it like in five minutes, how all the major flaws came to light with one user in one interaction, I think that was the beginning of the end of,
She couldn't get the butane in it. When he went to start it, he shocked his finger. He used it for a little bit, the mouthpiece fell off and he broke his lip. And I remember seeing Adam's face just like he knew that these were problems, but when he saw it like in five minutes, how all the major flaws came to light with one user in one interaction, I think that was the beginning of the end of,|||她无法把丁烷灌进去（注：原文he/She混用）。当他试图启动它时，他的手指被电了一下（注：原文shocked his finger，此处指静电或机械卡顿）。他用了一会儿，咬嘴掉下来把嘴唇磕破了。我记得看到亚当的表情，就好像他知道这些都是问题，但当他亲眼看到在短短五分钟内，一个用户在一次互动中就暴露出了所有重大缺陷时，我认为那是结束的开始——
okay, we need to recalibrate, go back to the drawing board, fix this thing. It's not ready for prime time. Something had to change, but it wasn't obvious what should be fixed first out of the plume's many, many problems. You're listening to Backfired on 99% Invisible, more after this.
okay, we need to recalibrate, go back to the drawing board, fix this thing. It's not ready for prime time. Something had to change, but it wasn't obvious what should be fixed first out of the plume's many, many problems. You're listening to Backfired on 99% Invisible, more after this.|||好吧，我们需要重新校准，回到图纸板前，修复这个东西。它还没准备好面向大众。有些事情必须改变，但在Plume众多大大小小的问题中，究竟该先修复哪一个，这并不明显。您正在收听的是99%隐形播客栏目《事与愿违》，广告之后更精彩。
According to emails we've seen from December of 2010, tensions started to emerge between Bowen and Monsey's. Bowen felt the company's number one goal should be pursuing deep lung nicotine delivery. The thing that, as he put it in one email, literally keeps smokers coming back for more. Monsey's worried that would essentially mean they were trying to make their device
According to emails we've seen from December of 2010, tensions started to emerge between Bowen and Monsey's. Bowen felt the company's number one goal should be pursuing deep lung nicotine delivery. The thing that, as he put it in one email, literally keeps smokers coming back for more. Monsey's worried that would essentially mean they were trying to make their device|||根据我们看到的2010年12月的电子邮件，鲍恩和蒙西斯之间开始出现紧张关系。鲍恩认为公司的首要目标应该是追求深肺尼古丁输送。正如他在一封电子邮件中所说的那样，这正是让烟民们欲罢不能、不断回购的法宝。蒙西斯则担心，这基本上意味着他们试图让自己的设备
as addictive as possible. He replied, if deep lung makes the product more enjoyable, then great. If the purpose is to keep people coming back for more, then I'm not sure I'm on board. Mansi's wanted people to plume because they enjoyed pluming, not because they were chemically addicted to it.
as addictive as possible. He replied, if deep lung makes the product more enjoyable, then great. If the purpose is to keep people coming back for more, then I'm not sure I'm on board. Mansi's wanted people to plume because they enjoyed pluming, not because they were chemically addicted to it.|||尽可能让人上瘾。他回复道，如果深肺吸入能让产品更令人愉悦，那很好。如果目的是让人不断回购，那么我不能确定我是否赞同。蒙西斯希望人们使用Plume是因为他们享受使用Plume的过程，而不是因为他们对它产生了化学成瘾。
Eventually, they settled on a compromise. They would focus on a new version of the plume that solved what Moncies euphemistically called its user interaction issues, while also researching improvements to nicotine delivery. But doing both of these things would require money. Money the company didn't have. In fact, early investors had seen the failure of the Plume Model 1 and assumed that Bowen and Monsey's would give up, that the future of smoking had been just another promising idea from Silicon Valley that ended up amounting to nothing much. But Bowen and Monsey's weren't ready to fold.
Eventually, they settled on a compromise. They would focus on a new version of the plume that solved what Moncies euphemistically called its user interaction issues, while also researching improvements to nicotine delivery. But doing both of these things would require money. Money the company didn't have. In fact, early investors had seen the failure of the Plume Model 1 and assumed that Bowen and Monsey's would give up, that the future of smoking had been just another promising idea from Silicon Valley that ended up amounting to nothing much. But Bowen and Monsey's weren't ready to fold.|||最终，他们达成了一种妥协。他们将专注于新版本的Plume，以解决蒙西斯委婉称为“用户交互问题”的缺陷，同时研究改进尼古丁输送方式。但要做这两件事都需要资金。而公司根本没有这笔钱。事实上，早期投资者看到了Plume 1型的失败，认为鲍恩和蒙西斯会放弃，认为吸烟的未来不过是硅谷又一个前途光明却最终不了了之的好创意。但鲍恩和蒙西斯并不打算就此认输。
Instead, they agreed to accept millions of dollars in investment capital from a Japanese tobacco company. Exactly the type of company they had set out to disrupt and frankly destroy. To Kurt Sonderager, it initially seemed like a deal with the devil. I was a little conflicted about it, but I also realized that why Japan Tobacco was doing it,
Instead, they agreed to accept millions of dollars in investment capital from a Japanese tobacco company. Exactly the type of company they had set out to disrupt and frankly destroy. To Kurt Sonderager, it initially seemed like a deal with the devil. I was a little conflicted about it, but I also realized that why Japan Tobacco was doing it,|||相反，他们同意接受一家日本烟草公司数百万美元的投资资本。这正是他们原本立志要颠覆、坦率地说要摧毁的那类公司。对库尔特·桑德拉格来说，这最初看起来就像是与魔鬼做交易。我对此感到有些纠结，但我也意识到日本烟草为什么要这么做，
because they weren't doing it to kill the technology as sometimes happens with tech companies, right? They buy a potential competitor and just kill it, wipe it out. They saw this also as the future. So if a big tobacco company in a smoking crazy country like Japan could come in and say, hey, this is the future of smoking.
because they weren't doing it to kill the technology as sometimes happens with tech companies, right? They buy a potential competitor and just kill it, wipe it out. They saw this also as the future. So if a big tobacco company in a smoking crazy country like Japan could come in and say, hey, this is the future of smoking.|||因为他们这样做并不是为了扼杀这项技术——科技公司有时会这样做，对吧？他们收购潜在的竞争对手然后将其扼杀、消灭。他们也将此视为未来。因此，如果像日本这样一个对吸烟极其狂热的国家的大型烟草公司能够介入并说，嘿，这就是吸烟的未来。
Great, keep going, guys. Keep innovating until you get it right. Plus, for Sonder Eger, it helped that Japan tobacco was Japanese. It didn't feel as bad as Altria or Philip Morris. Do you know what I mean? It's Japan tobacco. It's all the way on the other side of the world.
Great, keep going, guys. Keep innovating until you get it right. Plus, for Sonder Eger, it helped that Japan tobacco was Japanese. It didn't feel as bad as Altria or Philip Morris. Do you know what I mean? It's Japan tobacco. It's all the way on the other side of the world.|||太棒了，伙计们，继续干吧。继续创新，直到你们把产品做好。另外，对桑德拉格来说，日本烟草是一家日本公司这一点也有所帮助。它感觉没有奥驰亚（Altria）或菲利普·莫里斯那么糟糕。你知道我的意思吗？这是日本烟草。它远在世界的另一端。
With the investment in hand, the new plan was to have a revamped product on the market, hopefully within a year or so. But Sonder Eger didn't want to wait that long and decided to move on from the company. So I departed. And what happened was instead of fixing the plume right away, they actually came out with the Pax. The Pax was Bowen and Monsey's solution to their cash flow problem. Officially, it was a loose-leaf vaporizer.
With the investment in hand, the new plan was to have a revamped product on the market, hopefully within a year or so. But Sonder Eger didn't want to wait that long and decided to move on from the company. So I departed. And what happened was instead of fixing the plume right away, they actually came out with the Pax. The Pax was Bowen and Monsey's solution to their cash flow problem. Officially, it was a loose-leaf vaporizer.|||有了这笔投资，新计划是希望在一年左右的时间内推出一款改版的产品。但桑德拉格不想等那么久，决定离开公司。所以我离职了。而实际情况是，他们没有立刻修复Plume，而是推出了Pax。Pax是鲍恩和蒙西斯解决现金流问题的方案。官方称，它是一款散叶雾化器。
Unofficially, it was a weed vape. It was funny because with the many investors that we talked to about this, quite often the first thing they would say, like under their breath, they would say, yeah, this is cool. Does it work for weed? You know? So when enough people ask you if it works for weed, you have to ask yourself, like, no, but we can make one that really works well for weed.
Unofficially, it was a weed vape. It was funny because with the many investors that we talked to about this, quite often the first thing they would say, like under their breath, they would say, yeah, this is cool. Does it work for weed? You know? So when enough people ask you if it works for weed, you have to ask yourself, like, no, but we can make one that really works well for weed.|||非官方地说，它是一款大麻电子烟。这很有趣，因为在我们与许多投资者谈论此事时，他们通常说的第一句话（压低声音）会是：是的，这很酷。它能用来抽大麻吗？你知道吗？所以，当足够多的人问你它能不能用来抽大麻时，你不得不问自己：虽然现在不能，但我们可以制造一款真正适合抽大麻的设备。
So I think that's what they did. Using their vaporization technology to help stoners wasn't exactly Bohn and Monsey's primary mission. But it was another compromise they were willing to make in order to keep the company afloat. And to their credit, they really didn't half-ass it. The Pax was born of a collaboration with Yves Behar, the Swiss designer best known for the SodaStream bottle and the Jawbone Bluetooth headset. It was like a two or three hundred dollar vaporizer and they sold hundreds of thousands of them. It was like the best selling vaporizer in the country for weed and it gave them what
所以我想这就是他们所做的。利用他们的雾化技术来帮助瘾君子并不是博恩和蒙西的主要使命，但这却是他们为了维持公司生存而愿意做出的又一次妥协。平心而论，他们真的没有敷衍了事。Pax 是与伊夫·贝哈尔（Yves Behar）合作诞生的，这位瑞士设计师以苏打水机瓶和 Jawbone 蓝牙耳机而闻名。这是一款售价两三百美元的雾化器，他们卖出了几十万个。它就像是国内最畅销的大麻雾化器，并为他们提供了
they needed. Finally, Bowen and Monsey's had a best selling product. And with the new influx of cash, they continued to refine the Plume. They also hired more employees. All I remember is going into then, where the customer service representatives worked, which was out of a supply closet with some retrofitted bathroom. And I thought, this is it.
他们需要的东西。最后，鲍恩和蒙西公司终于有了一款畅销产品。随着新资金的涌入，他们继续改进 Plume。他们还雇用了更多员工。我只记得当时走进客服人员工作的地方，那是一个带改装浴室的杂物间。我想，就是这里了。
This is the dream. I was so pumped to be there. Lorenzo Castillo was still in college when he joined Plume to work part time as a customer service representative. It was exactly what he hoped for. The company was still small, but growing. It had a strong happy hour culture,
这就是梦想。能在那里我太兴奋了。洛伦佐·卡斯蒂略（Lorenzo Castillo）加入 Plume 兼职担任客服代表时还在上大学。这完全符合他的期望。公司规模虽小，但正在成长。它有着浓厚的欢乐时光文化，
no rules against vaping in the office, and his team had a habit of dressing up in suits and ties on Fridays, since every other day people wore t-shirts and jeans. In other words, it was a lot of fun. We would wait for the leadership team to come back from lunch. And when they would, we would shoot foam darts at them. And this is one of the videos where we're just barraging them with foam darts as they walk in.
办公室里没有禁止吸电子烟的规定，而且他的团队习惯在周五穿西装打领带，因为其他日子大家都是穿 T 恤和牛仔裤。换句话说，这非常有趣。我们会等着领导团队吃完午饭回来。当他们回来时，我们会向他们发射泡沫飞镖。这是其中的一段视频，里面记录了他们走进来时，我们正用泡沫飞镖对他们进行狂轰滥炸。
You can see James catch one and shoot it back at us. And that was kind of, he sat right next to us. That was like part of what enabled us to have that fun atmosphere, that he wasn't beyond having a little fun in situations like that. Castillo loved the packs, as did all of his friends. When it came to like Secret Santa for the couple years that I worked there, I would bring a Pax and that was always a big hit. I mean, in my mind, right, this is it.
你可以看到詹姆斯抓住一个并向我们射回来。这就有点像——他就坐在我们旁边。这也是促成那种有趣氛围的一部分，他在那种情况下并不介意找点乐子。卡斯蒂略很喜欢 Pax，他的所有朋友也是如此。在我工作的头几年里，每逢秘密圣诞老人（Secret Santa）活动，我都会带一个 Pax，这总是大受欢迎。我的意思是，在我的脑海里，对吧，就是这个。
This is the product, right? A discreet way to smoke pot where you don't have to burn anything. But he also understood that the device wasn't the company's main ambition. I always saw the Pax as a pleasant diversion from the mission that James and Adam had initially set out on. I think they really wanted to reinvent tobacco and how it was consumed, as opposed to creating a discrete way for people to vaporize pot. Even as sales of the packs took off, Bowen and Monsey's were still focused on improving the design of the next version of the plume, the Model 2.
这就是这款产品，对吧？一种无需燃烧就能抽大麻的隐秘方式。但他也明白，这款设备并不是公司的主要雄心。我一直把 Pax 视为对詹姆斯和亚当最初设定的使命的一种愉快转移。我认为他们真正想要的是重新发明烟草及其消费方式，而不是为人们创造一种隐秘吸大麻的方法。尽管 Pax 的销量腾飞，但鲍恩和蒙西公司仍然专注于改进下一版本 Plume（即 2 代）的设计。
Crucially, they switched from a butane heat source to a USB rechargeable battery. So no more unpleasant shocks. And I actually have one. I have a model too. I brought it in. You have one in your pocket right now? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it's funny, like, it's, you know, you look on this and it's fairly discreet. Of course, it's dead as hell. But it's still got, this is probably my favorite thing. It's still got a rocket pod in it. And if you want, you can smell it and you can still smell the rocket pod if you twist it out. Wow. That was my favorite flavor, rocket. I don't even know how I would describe this flavor it doesn't smell like something that exists
至关重要的是，他们将丁烷热源改为了 USB 可充电电池。所以再也没有令人不快的电击了。我实际上有一个。我有一个 2 代。我把它带来了。你现在口袋里就有一个？对，对，对。有趣的是，你看这个，它相当隐蔽。当然，它完全没电了。但它依然有——这是我最喜欢的东西。它里面还有一个烟弹。如果你愿意，你可以闻一闻，如果把它扭下来，你仍然能闻到烟弹的味道。哇。那是我最喜欢的口味，火箭味。我甚至不知道该如何形容这种味道，它闻起来不像是存在于
in nature. Some people including myself say Christmas but yeah no I hear you I think it's got like a cinnamon hit to it it just you know how they say smell is like the biggest hit of nostalgia smelling that brings me back to those times. The Plume Model 2 was launched in 2013 with a swanky party in San Francisco. The company also co-sponsored a New York Fashion Week album release party for Robin Thicke. According to the New York Times, most attendees were a bit confused by the plume. A brand ambassador had to explain to users, they're very popular, very international.
自然界中的东西。包括我在内的一些人说是圣诞节，但，是的，我明白你的意思，我觉得它有点肉桂的味道，你知道人们怎么说气味是最强烈的怀旧触发器，闻到那个味道就把我带回了那些时光。Plume 2 代于 2013 年在旧金山的一场豪华派对上发布。该公司还联合赞助了罗宾·西科（Robin Thicke）的纽约时装周专辑发布派对。据《纽约时报》报道，大多数出席者对 Plume 感到有些困惑。品牌大使不得不向用户解释，它们非常受欢迎，非常国际化。
They smell like cookies. Glitz and confusion aside, the hope was that, finally, the company could build on the success of the packs with an e-stigaret that actually worked. Anything Model 2 that came in was treated with white glove service. We were told to escalate that to our more senior customer service representatives and to really thoroughly work with those customers in terms of what's wrong, how can we help you. I think that really showed where the priorities were for that company at that time.
它们闻起来像曲奇饼干。抛开浮华和困惑不谈，人们希望这家公司最终能凭借一款真正好用的电子烟，在 Pax 的成功基础上再创辉煌。任何送修的 2 代产品都会受到贵宾般的待遇。我们被告知要将这些问题升级给更高级的客服代表，并与这些客户彻底沟通，了解哪里出了问题以及我们能如何提供帮助。我认为这确实表明了当时该公司将重心放在了哪里。
Bowen and Monsey's were eager to get feedback from customers about the new and improved version of their device. The problem was there weren't that many Model 2 customers to learn from. I remember we had an All Hands. And during that All Hands, an engineer who was, I'm not going to name names, but was known to be vocal, rose his hand and said, exactly how many Model 2s have been sold. I remember that being a palpably awkward moment where it was clear that it wasn't the hit that I think we wanted it to be as a company.
鲍恩和蒙西公司急于收集客户对他们这款改进型新设备的反馈。问题是，没有那么多 2 代客户可供了解。我记得我们开过一次全体员工大会。在那次大会上，有一位工程师——我不点名了，但他以直言不讳著称——举手问道，到底卖出了多少台 2 代。我记得那是一个明显令人尴尬的时刻，很显然它并没有取得我们公司所希望的那种成功。
The Plume Model 2 had been an improvement on the Model 1, but it still had many of the same problems. The mouthpiece felt fragile and it had to be recharged every three or four uses. Crucially, it didn't solve the problem Bowen had now been highlighting for years. It still didn't deliver enough nicotine to satisfy smokers. Heating was a problem with the Model 2. There was some inconsistencies with the mixtures because it was still a leaf-based product with the pods. And I think that led to a less than desired user experience.
Plume 2 代是对 1 代的改进，但它仍然存在许多相同的问题。烟嘴感觉很脆弱，每使用三四次就必须重新充电。至关重要的是，它没有解决鲍恩多年来一直强调的问题。它仍然无法输送足够的尼古丁来满足吸烟者的需求。加热是 2 代的一个问题。混合物存在一些不一致性，因为烟弹仍然是基于烟叶的产品。我认为这导致了不尽如人意的用户体验。
It was clear the entire way the Model 2 worked by vaporizing tobacco leaves just wasn't delivering a satisfying amount of nicotine. So Bowen and Monsey's went back to the tobacco documents they had first discovered while they were at Stanford. That was where they hit upon secret research from R.J. Reynolds into something called nicotine salts. The documents showed that in the 1980s, scientists at the company reported that combining pure nicotine with an acid would create a special kind of salt. This salt eliminated the unpleasant effects that came with increasing the concentration of nicotine.
很明显，2 代通过加热烟草叶来产生蒸气的整个工作方式，就是无法输送令人满意的尼古丁含量。因此，鲍恩和蒙西公司重新查阅了他们在斯坦福大学时首次发现的烟草文件。正是在那里，他们看到了雷诺公司（R.J. Reynolds）关于一种叫做“尼古丁盐”的物质的秘密研究。文件显示，在 20 世纪 80 年代，该公司的科学家报告称，将纯尼古丁与酸结合会产生一种特殊的盐。这种盐消除了随着尼古丁浓度增加而带来的令人不适的副作用。
But R.J. Reynolds had never commercialized this breakthrough. Apparently they were concerned that it would produce such a smooth cigarette that people wouldn't realize they were smoking way too much, and that they would just keep smoking until they accidentally overdosed on nicotine. This seemed like a really promising potential solution, but only if Bohen and Monsi's were willing to completely redesign how their nicotine vape worked. Instead of vaporizing tobacco leaves like the Model 2, a new device would need to mix
但雷诺公司从未将这一突破商业化。显然，他们担心这会造出如此顺喉的香烟，以至于人们不会意识到自己抽得太多，从而会一直抽下去，直到不小心尼古丁过量。这看起来是一个非常有前景的潜在解决方案，但前提是鲍恩和蒙西公司愿意彻底重新设计他们的尼古丁电子烟的工作方式。新设备不再像 2 代那样加热烟草叶，而是需要将
nicotine in a liquid that would then be heated as an aerosol. This would require expertise that went far beyond Bowen and Monsi's Stanford design credentials. So, they hired a chemist to help. Her name was Chen Weixing. They were a strong team with mechanical engineering background and product design, but they didn't have anybody with chemistry training.
尼古丁混合在液体中，然后加热成气溶胶。这将需要远超鲍恩和蒙西斯坦福设计资历的专业知识。因此，他们雇了一位化学家来帮忙。她叫陈维星（Chen Weixing）。他们是一个拥有机械工程背景和产品设计能力的强大团队，但他们没有受过化学培训的人。
And that's why they had this opening. Xing had a PhD in chemical engineering. She'd worked for big pharmaceutical companies on things like asthma inhalers and an inhalable migraine drug. Xing did not respond to our request to speak with her. So what you're hearing is an interview she did with Bloomberg in 2019. I told specifically to the recruiter in the beginning that I was not a smoker and I don't
这就是他们有这个空缺的原因。星拥有化学工程博士学位。她曾在各大制药公司从事哮喘吸入器和可吸入偏头痛药物等工作。星没有回应我们采访她的请求。所以你听到的是她在 2019 年接受彭博社采访的录音。我一开始就明确对招聘人员说我不是烟民，我也不
plan to start smoking. And then they said it's not a requirement, even though many of their team, they are smokers. Xing recalled that Bowen and Monsi's were actually pluming during her job interview. It was not as annoying at all as somebody smoking next to you. She also recalled that they seemed aware that some scientists in the field of healthcare might be hesitant to work on a tobacco-related product. But I actually hold different views on that
打算开始吸烟。然后他们说这不是必需的，尽管他们的许多团队成员都是烟民。星回忆说，鲍恩和蒙西在对她进行工作面试时实际上正在抽 Plume。这根本不像有人在你旁边抽烟那么烦人。她还回忆说，他们似乎意识到医疗保健领域的某些科学家可能对从事与烟草相关的产品有所犹豫。但我实际上对此持有不同的看法，
because I think being somebody develops medications, right, or drugs, it's actually to treat sickness. But I do see smoking as a behavior causing a lot of health problem and then causing a lot of stress on public health space in general. Xing took the job in 2013 and set about trying to figure out how to deliver a nicotine hit that would convert serious smokers.
因为我认为作为一个开发药物的人，实际上是为了治疗疾病。但我确实认为吸烟是一种导致许多健康问题的行为，并对整个公共卫生空间造成了很大的压力。星于 2013 年接受了这份工作，并着手弄清楚如何提供能够改变重度吸烟者的尼古丁击喉感。
It would need to have just enough burn and a little hit to the back of the throat, but it couldn't be too harsh to handle. Xing conducted her research in a lab that was set apart from the rest of the office. Lorenzo Castillo, the customer service rep, thinks that was not an accident. I remember being like, how they're really putting research under lock and key. You don't walk by engineering anymore. Engineering is on the far side of the building. And that to me was like,
它需要恰到好处的灼烧感和一点对喉咙后部的冲击，但又不能太刺鼻而难以忍受。星在与办公室其余部分隔开的实验室里进行研究。客服代表洛伦佐·卡斯蒂略认为这并非偶然。我记得当时觉得，他们把研究锁得真严实啊。你再也走不到工程部那边了。工程部在大楼的最远端。这对我来说就像是，
there's definitely like a different part of the building for them. They were really working on something special back there and they wanted to limit distractions. Working closely with Bowen, Xing mixed different formulas of e-liquids and recruited coworkers to give feedback on the flavor and the nicotine hit.
大楼里确实有一个对他们来说不同的区域。他们在后面真的在研究一些特别的东西，他们希望减少干扰。星与鲍恩紧密合作，混合了不同配方的电子烟液，并招募同事对口味和尼古丁击喉感提供反馈。
They called this buzz testing. Castillo remembered that his boss was one of the people who opted in to trying the new technology. She was a cigarette smoker, and she volunteered. Xing documented her test subjects' reactions to the new formulation. She wanted to know, did their heart rate increase? Did they get a throat hit? Did they feel a buzz? I remember being like, whoa, that's new. They're doing something that is a lot more data intensive
他们称之为“过瘾测试”（buzz testing）。卡斯蒂略记得他的老板是自愿尝试新技术的几个人之一。她是一名烟民，而且她是自愿的。星记录了她的测试对象对新配方的反应。她想知道，他们的心率加快了吗？他们有击喉感吗？他们有兴奋感（buzz）吗？我记得当时觉得，哇，这很新颖。他们正在做的事情比我们过去做过的任何事情
than anything we've done in the past. Eventually it became clear that nicotine salts were delivering a hit that was way, way stronger than anything Plume One or Two could give you. Xing had cracked the code. When those volunteers came to you and say that they haven't touched their cigarette pack for a while. I do think that we have a great product and we should let more people try it. On October 10, 2014, Bowen and Xing filed a patent to protect their innovation. In their application, they reported having quote, unexpectedly discovered that certain
都更加依赖数据。最终显而易见的是，尼古丁盐带来的冲击比 Plume 一代或二代所能提供的要强得多、多得多。星破解了密码。当这些志愿者来到你面前说他们已经有一段时间没碰过烟盒时。我确实认为我们有一款很棒的产品，我们应该让更多的人尝试。2014 年 10 月 10 日，鲍恩和星提交了一项专利，以保护他们的创新。他们在申请中报告称，“意外发现”某些
nicotine liquid formulations provide satisfaction that was similar to smoking a traditional cigarette. In fact, their formulation was so strong that it made users' heart rates skyrocket higher and faster than if they just smoked. In other words, it had the potential to be even more addictive. While Bowen and Xing were at work on the nicotine formula, Monsey started thinking about a new design for their new device. He wanted it to be more like the PAX. PAX was that aesthetic was born out of everybody
尼古丁液体配方提供了类似于吸传统香烟的满足感。事实上，他们的配方如此强烈，以至于使用者的心率飙升得比单纯抽烟更高、更快。换句话说，它有可能让人上瘾。正当鲍恩和星致力于尼古丁配方时，蒙西开始考虑为他们的新设备设计新外观。他希望它更像 PAX。PAX 的这种美学诞生于团队每个人
on the team's immediate, you know, instinctual distaste for this 420 aesthetic. Josh Morinstein was a designer at the firm that worked on the PAX. He remembers one detail in particular from his early interactions with Bowen and Monsies. The main thing I remember was that they were constantly, constantly vaping. Constantly.
对这种 420 美学的本能厌恶之中。乔什·莫林斯坦（Josh Morinstein）是参与 PAX 设计的公司的设计师。他清晰地记得他与鲍恩和蒙西早期交往中的一个细节。我记得最主要的一点是，他们一直在、不停地抽电子烟。一直在抽。
And there was a giant bowl, like a salad bowl, that had hundreds of multicolored plume pots. Those were the little Nespresso guys. and then there was another bowl that had hundreds of used pods and they would go through them constantly, they were constantly sucking on these things. Monsi's wanted their new device to be easier to use than the plume, something that people would want to keep in their pocket and something they'd want to show off. The main component of the brief was, let's design something that has permanence, to use this word, and the idea was to create something that was reusable,
那里有一个巨大的碗，就像沙拉碗一样，里面有数百个多颜色的 Plume 烟弹。那些就像是小 Nespresso（奈斯派索）胶囊。然后还有另一个碗，里面有数百个用过的烟弹，他们会不断地翻找它们，他们一直在吮吸这些东西。蒙西希望他们的新设备比 Plume 更易于使用，是那种人们愿意放在口袋里、愿意拿出来炫耀的东西。任务简介的主要部分是：让我们设计一种具有“永恒性”的产品——借用这个词——其理念是创造一种可重复使用、
and rechargeable, and refillable. People have to want this thing that has to feel special. Monsey has offered Morinstein and his partner a contract for a few weeks of design work on this new concept. They agreed to take on the project and came up with a whole host of designs. Finally, when they felt they were almost tapped out. We said, is there anything that we've kind of left
可充电且可重新灌装的东西。人们必须想要这个感觉很特别的东西。蒙西向莫林斯坦和他的合伙人提供了一份合同，让他们为这个新概念进行几周的设计工作。他们同意接下这个项目，并想出了各种各样的设计。最后，当他们觉得灵感快要枯竭时。我们说，还有什么我们没有
undiscovered? And I think I said, what would it be like to smoke in the future? Would you really use a cylinder? And this is all based off of the way that traditional tobacco is manufactured and processed and rolled. And I had a USB key on my key chain,
发掘的吗？我想我当时说，未来的吸烟会是什么样子的？你真的会用圆柱体吗？这一切都是基于传统烟草的制造、加工和卷制方式。我的钥匙链上有一个 USB 钥匙，
which was a tiny little rectilinear form, and it was sheet metal that was rolled and those are pretty inexpensive. And I said, what if it was like this? Like a USB stick. He put the one on his key chain up to his lips. And it felt better than trying to wrap your mouth around a circular shape.
它是一个微小的直角矩形形状，是用卷起来的薄板金属制成的，而且相当便宜。我说，如果它是这样的呢？就像一个 USB 棒。他把钥匙链上的那个放在嘴唇上。这比试图把嘴包在一个圆形形状上要舒服。
Morinstein and his partner dubbed this version the Slab, and they got to work drawing up the concept. They decided that you should be able to charge the device by sticking it into your computer, just like a USB stick. In June of 2013, they presented the Slab to Bowen and Monsey's. We have the original presentation here that we shared with the team at Jewel.
莫林斯坦和他的合伙人将这个版本命名为 Slab，他们开始着手绘制这个概念。他们决定，你应该能够通过将设备插入电脑来为它充电，就像 USB 棒一样。2013 年 6 月，他们向鲍恩和蒙西展示了 Slab。我们这里有最初的演示文稿，当时是和 Juul 的团队分享的。
The PowerPoint shows the product already named Jewel. Morinstein didn't know when or how that name had been decided, but he recalled Bowen and Monsey's already having settled on it before he was hired. Bowen would later clarify that the name was inspired by jewels, like gems, and jewel, the scientific unit of energy.
PowerPoint 显示该产品已经命名为 Juul。莫林斯坦不知道这个名字是什么时候以及如何决定的，但他回忆说，在他被雇佣之前，鲍恩和蒙西就已经敲定了这个名字。鲍恩后来澄清说，这个名字灵感来自于 jewels（珠宝，如宝石）以及 joule（焦耳，能量的科学单位）。
And you can see in this image here, when you're holding it almost in a traditional cigarette format, you know, it kind of sits between the fingers in a slim way, and it's actually more comfortable than a cylinder would be. And they were just immediately like, this is it, this is the one. Yeah, there was no question, this is the one.
你可以从这张图片中看到，当你几乎以传统香烟的握法拿着它时，你知道，它以一种纤细的方式夹在手指之间，实际上比圆柱体更舒服。他们立刻就说，就是这个，就是这个。是的，毫无疑问，就是这个。
At this point in our interview, Morinstein put away the PowerPoint and pulled out one of the early prototypes of the jewel. Can I hold this jewel prototype? Yeah. It's remarkably similar to the jewel we know and love today. It's probably the most famous thing I've ever designed, for sure. At the end, I think we made $16,000 on it.
在我们采访的这个阶段，莫林斯坦收起了 PowerPoint，拿出了 Juul 的早期原型之一。我可以拿一下这个 Juul 原型吗？可以。它和我们今天认识并热爱的 Juul 惊人地相似。这肯定是我设计过的最著名的东西。最后，我想我们靠它赚了 16,000 美元。
Morinstein went on to design the fellow Gooseneck kettle, the Open Spaces shoe rack, and Athena Club razors. But the jewel is far and away the most recognizable product he's ever designed. That's because it's one of the most recognizable products of the 21st century, like the iPhone and the Tesla Model 3. Like smartphones and cars, e-cigarettes had existed long before the jewel came along. But it was Morinstein's design that made the jewel stand out. Frankly, I think we did a good job.
莫林斯坦后来设计了 Fellow 鹅颈壶、Open Spaces 鞋架和 Athena Club 剃须刀。但 Juul 远称得上他设计过的最具辨识度的产品。那是因为它是 21 世纪最具辨识度的产品之一，就像 iPhone 和特斯拉 Model 3 一样。就像智能手机和汽车一样，电子烟在 Juul 出现之前很久就存在了。但正是莫林斯坦的设计让 Juul 脱颖而出。坦率地说，我觉得我们干得不错。
You know what I mean? Like, I'm like, oh, we kind of nailed it. Yeah, it's iconic. Yeah. And that's what we were hired to do. By early 2015, Adam Bowen and James Monsey's were finally ready to release the jewel into the world. Ten years after first presenting their idea to their classmates at Stanford. They started agreeing to interviews, like the one you heard at the beginning of this episode,
你知道我的意思吗？就像，我觉得，哦，我们算是成功拿下了。是的，它是标志性的。是的，这就是我们被雇佣要做的事。到 2015 年初，亚当·鲍恩和詹姆斯·蒙西终于准备好将 Juul 推向世界了。距离他们在斯坦福大学向同学首次展示他们的想法已经过去了十年。他们开始同意接受采访，就像你在本集开头听到的一样，
where Monsi's teased their upcoming product launch. So, let's talk about this year. What is next? What's in store for you guys? A lot of great stuff. It's all a top secret. Yeah, we'll have more than one really awesome new product out this year.
蒙西在那里透露了他们即将推出的产品发布。那么，我们来谈谈今年。接下来是什么？你们有什么新计划？很多棒极了的东西。这都是绝密。是的，我们今年将推出不止一款真正棒极了的新产品。
One really awesome new product out this year. One really awesome new product. When Kurt Sonderager got his hands on the jewel, he was really impressed with how far Bowen and Monsi's had come from the prototype they showed him back in 2007. What did you think? You know, they definitely fixed the product. In every sense of the word, it was super easy.
今年推出一款真正棒极了的新产品。一款真正棒极了的新产品。当库尔特·松德雷格（Kurt Sonderager）拿到 Juul 时，他对鲍恩和蒙西自 2007 年向他展示原型以来所取得的进展印象深刻。你觉得怎么样？你知道，他们确实把产品修好了。从字面意义上讲，它超级简单。
There were no pain points. There was no butane. There was no shock. It was easy to put a pot in and take a pot out. So I knew it was going to be pretty big. I didn't have any idea how big it actually got. He only had one concern. What if Bowen and Monsey's had made their product a little too good? I gave it to one of my buddies, Owen's a here in Encinitas and he was a heavy smoker. And he finally completely gave up on cigarettes and when I gave him his jewel he told me,
没有任何痛点。没有丁烷。没有电击。放入烟弹和取出烟弹都很容易。所以我知道它会变得相当大。我当时根本不知道它实际会有多火。他只有一个担忧。如果鲍恩和蒙西把他们的产品做得太好了怎么办？我把它送给我的一个死党欧恩，他在恩西尼塔斯（Encinitas），他是个老烟枪。他终于彻底戒掉了香烟，当我把 Juul 交给他时，他告诉我，
he said, shit, I feel like I'm addicted again. This season on Backfired will take you inside Jewel's Rise and its precipitous fall. I didn't understand until it clicked you can smoke the Jewel wherever you want. Blue craze and e-cigarettes, it's called Jewel and it is flying off the shelves. This thing is really sexy and disruptive. There is such a thing as a company growing too fast. Jewel grew too fast. I'm going to go over a couple different ways to hit your jewel while you're in school and not get caught. We literally called our bathroom the Jewel Room. Tonight, authorities investigating what could be the country's first death linked to vaping.
他说，靠，我觉得我又上瘾了。本季的《Backfired》将带你深入了解 Juul 的崛起及其急剧陨落。直到我反应过来，我才明白你在任何地方都可以抽 Juul。蓝风暴（Blue craze）和电子烟，它叫 Juul，正卖得火热。这东西真的很性感、很有颠覆性。公司发展太快也是个问题。Juul 发展得太快了。我要讲几种在学校抽 Juul 却不被抓的不同方法。我们直截了当把我们的洗手间叫做 Juul 房。今晚，当局正在调查这是否可能是该国首例与电子烟相关的死亡事件。
I think it was the beginning of the end for Juul. We'll also hear from the co-founder of Juul, James Monsies, who has not spoken publicly about the company in nearly half a decade. We could have done a lot better job collectively of dealing with this if we hadn't been so focused on finding a new enemy so quickly. We'll meet the new owners of the next generation of vape companies and the frustrated authorities who have been powerless to rein them in. We invested about $2 million and we blew it up immediately into a multi-million dollar
我认为这是 Juul 末日的开始。我们还将听到 Juul 联合创始人詹姆斯·蒙西的访谈，他已有近五年没有公开谈论过这家公司了。如果我们没有那么专注于这么快地寻找一个新敌人，我们本可以集体把应对这件事的工作做得好得多。我们将结识新一代电子烟公司的新老板，以及那些无力控制他们的沮丧当局。我们投资了大约 200 万美元，它在 90 天内就迅速膨胀成了一家价值数百万美元的
company within 90 days. It's like imagine you're walking down the street and someone's like, here take this like 500 bucks like run, run, run, run. We didn't predict what I now believe is an epidemic of e-cigarette use among teenagers. It was a witch's brew of public health concerns. The teens are very clever. They seem to evade where the regulations go. US agents recently seized more than 1.4 million illegal e-cigarettes. It can almost feel like a game of, you know, Whack-a-Mole.
公司。这就好比想象你走在街上，有人说，来，拿着这 500 块钱，快跑、跑、跑、跑。我们没有预测到我现在认为是青少年中电子烟使用流行病的现象。这是公共卫生担忧的大杂烩。现在的青少年非常聪明。他们似乎总能避开监管。美国特工最近查获了超过 140 万个非法电子烟。这几乎感觉像是一场“打地鼠”游戏。
And finally, I'll try to figure out how to end my own personal vaping war, or at least come to some sort of truce. My mom doesn't really know about any of this, so I'm contemplating how I will talk about it on the podcast if I will. Yeah. I feel like a great way to tell your parents about your nicotine addiction is to launch
最后，我将努力找出如何结束我个人的电子烟战争，或者至少达成某种停战协议。我妈妈其实对这一切都一无所知，所以我正在考虑我是否以及如何在播客中谈论它。是的。我觉得向父母讲述你尼古丁上瘾的一个绝佳方式就是开办
a podcast series. Backfired is presented by Audible Originals and Prologue Projects. The show is hosted by Leon Neyfok and me, Arielle Pardes. Our senior producer was Sam Lee. Our editor was Kim Gittelson. Our producers were Dustin DeSoto and Catherine Sullivan. Our assistant producer was Arlene Arevalo. Sound design by Andrew Parsons.
一个播客系列。《Backfired》由 Audible Originals 和 Prologue Projects 联合出品。本节目由莱昂·奈福克（Leon Neyfok）和我阿里尔·帕德斯（Arielle Pardes）主持。我们的高级制作人是萨姆·李（Sam Lee）。我们的编辑是金·吉特尔森（Kim Gittelson）。我们的制作人是达斯汀·德索托（Dustin DeSoto）和凯瑟琳·沙利文（Catherine Sullivan）。我们的助理制作人是阿琳·阿雷瓦洛（Arlene Arevalo）。声音设计由安德鲁·帕森斯（Andrew Parsons）完成。
Archival research and fact checking by Francis Carr. Our theme song and score were composed by Emma Munger. Audio mix by Erica Wong. Copyright counsel provided by Peter Yasi and Brandon Butler at Yasi Butler PLLC. Heather Juan Teserero is our executive producer at Audible Originals. Mike Charzak is the head of production at Audible Studios.
档案研究和事实核查由弗朗西斯·卡尔（Francis Carr）负责。我们的主题曲和配乐由埃玛·芒格（Emma Munger）作曲。音频混音由埃里卡·黄（Erica Wong）完成。版权法律顾问由 Yasi Butler PLLC 的彼得·亚西（Peter Yasi）和布兰登·巴特勒（Brandon Butler）担任。希瑟·胡安·特塞雷罗（Heather Juan Teserero）是我们 Audible Originals 的执行制作人。迈克·查扎克（Mike Charzak）是 Audible Studios 的制作主管。
Rachel Giazza is Audible's chief content officer. Special thanks to Gabriel Montoya and Thomas Perfetti. Backfired was co-created by Kim Gittleson for Prologue Projects. Sound recording copyright 2024 by Prologue Projects. You can find the full season of Backfired for free if you're an Audible subscriber. It's created by the team at Prologue Projects, which has produced many excellent podcast
雷切尔·贾扎（Rachel Giazza）是 Audible 的首席内容官。特别感谢加布里埃尔·蒙托亚（Gabriel Montoya）和托马斯·佩尔费蒂（Thomas Perfetti）。《Backfired》由金·吉特尔森为 Prologue Projects 共同创建。录音版权 2024 年归 Prologue Projects 所有。如果您是 Audible 订阅者，您可以免费收听整季的《Backfired》。它由 Prologue Projects 团队创作，该团队制作了许多由莱昂·奈福克主持的优秀的播客
documentaries hosted by Leon Neyfok, including many seasons of Fiasco and Think Twice, Michael Jackson. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
纪录片，包括多季的《Fiasco》以及《Think Twice, Michael Jackson》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。